good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation before we get started
with our public hearings if I can ask
represent of sellers to lead us in the
pledge
thank you for that uh being 9:31 I'm
open the public hearing on House Bill
1063 FN Rel relative to motor vehicle
speed within 10 mph of the speed limit
and the chair recognizes the prime
welcome thank you Mr chair this bill
affects when someone can be stopped or
ticketed for speeding now how many of us
went at least one mile above the speed
limit on the way here today you don't
have to answer I expect the answer is
every single one of us um which leads to
the question if lawmakers aren't
following the law how can we expect the
public to um so obviously police aren't
pulling people over for doing 31 and a
30 um but the question is at what point
do they pull someone over so I expect
police will be here to testify against
the bill and I think you might want to
ask them hey what's the average speed
someone's doing above the speed limit
before you pull them over and maybe the
minimum speed um above the speed limit
that you would pull someone over um
because I think that might be pretty in
line with what this spill actually uh
would attempt to do the problem with
allowing police to pull people over when
they're doing 31 to 30 is at least to
pretextual stops so I don't want to give
ulterior or impute motives on someone
but I suggest that some Police pull
people over for reasons other than they
might be telling that person or for
reasons other than what the actual speed
is um maybe it's night time the officer
has nothing better to do and just wants
to see if he smells an odor of alcohol
on someone's breath um maybe it's for
some other reasons related to the
characteristics of the driver or
something related to the vehicle that
gives an officer a hunch I'm just going
to stop this person but we shouldn't
have laws that are can be enforced in
such an erratic manner when it's
literally something that pretty much
everyone is doing um so New Hampshire
has a in my opinion kind of a unique
speeding law so it's not actually
against the law to speed as long as
you're what's called driving reasonably
and prudent now that's not defined um
but the statute goes on to say it's I
might mispronounce it Prima fascia
evidence that it isn't reasonable when
prudent if you are going above the speed
limit and it's fancy legal term
basically it's a pre uh it's a
rebuttable presumption so I mean if I
ever had someone pulled over for 31 and
30 I think at the end of the day judge
would agree with me that if everything
else is fine that hey that's a
reasonable impudent speed um now I think
a lot of so just because something's
generally reasonable doesn't always mean
it is so if there's snow on the ground
if it's nighttime if it's foggy a bunch
of rain a bunch of traffic might not be
reasonable to do 31 in that 30 or
speeding on the highway as it may be so
what this bill does is it would say
instead of just driving in excess of the
speed limit that if you are within 10
miles or above the speed limit then that
in itself is reasonable prudent and I
think that aligns up with when officers
are pulling people over so I routinely
see people drive by officers going above
10 m hour above the speed limit and they
aren't getting pulled over um so we
could pick any number I happen to pick
10 I think that's generally where
officers probably pull someone over but
I think it a good question for people to
ask the police at what speed they do
actually pull this over but that's what
this bill does and I'm happy to answer
any questions about
it thank you sir and I apologize um any
questions from the
committee of
sellers sure thank you Mr chair uh
thanks for Tak the question uh how' you
come up with 10 miles an hour and 10
miles an hour over 30 miles an hour is
quite a big difference why not use a
percentage like 15% over the over the
limit that way it's more adjustable as
the limit goes up I'm thinking like 70
miles an hour it be Co towards 80 and 30
m an hour it be what 34 you know four or
five miles over that's a good point um
that is an approach I would support that
um besides if you were to go that route
um perhaps other than 15 or let's just
say 10% um I think we generally have
like a lot of different categories so 30
tends to be a com common um one or 40 um
55 65 the issue I guess if you're
picking like 15% if the speed Li is 65
it's kind of hard to figure out what 15%
of that is um so if you were to go that
approach maybe it's better to say well
in 65 you can do 7
um or in 30 35 but um I just had to come
up with a number times what I came up
with because um but I would support any
approach that you guys think is
reasonable hand prudent any other
questions from the
committee seeing nothing thank you very
much thank you uh next up chair
recognizes Dan Goodman from Triple A
minutes
good morning uh for the record uh
chairman WS thank you very much for
allowing me to testify and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Dan Goodman I'm the public affairs
manager for AAA Northern New England um
I'm here in opposition to this bill um
mainly for a traffic safety concern
speeding is a growing growing issue in
New Hampshire and around the country and
very concerned about if we allow people
to speed even uh more I'm I'm sure
someone from do will be here to explain
how they set the speed limit so when
we're driving down the interstate at 65
we should be going 65 at the most
perfect conditions and a lot of
engineering and research has gone into
that um we speeding is now about a third
of all fatalities in this country
right up there with alcohol impair
driving um it is anecdotally we see it
every day we read
about crazy speeds on the highway
through Greenland Hampton on 95 a major
major concern we believe so to help
understand the impact of speeding we
have a aleaa foundation for Traffic
Safety down in Washington DC it's it's
one of the preeminent Traffic Safety
foundations out there and they have
released a couple studies over the last
couple years to understand how speeding
affects a driver how speeding affects
the
vehicle I'll just be real quick here the
first study they looked at um looked at
the effects of of an injury and a crash
at 40 miles an hour 50 miles an hour and
56 miles an hour the study found that
crash speeds increase modestly more
structural damage to the vehicle and
greater forces onto the dummy's entire
body resulting in increased severity of
injuries which canel out most Vehicle
Safety technology like airbags and
improved structural
designs um the second study looked at 12
roadways across the country um that some
that had increases speed limit and some
that had decreased the speed limit and
at 2third of the interstates that had
increased the speed limit um there was
an increased crash
frequency um if you've ever traveled to
Maine north of Portland in 2014
increaseed speed limit on i295 from
Portland to Falmouth 2014 to 2017 or 18
that was reversed in four years because
they saw an increased number of crashes
and fatalities and since then they've
seen fatals and crashes um I think I
said they saw it was an increase and so
they' since they've put the speedet down
to 65 those crashes and fatalities have
decreased um nationally over the last 10
years we've seen 77% increase in p
estrian
fatalities and with a increasing
contributing factor of
speeding um we we we release an annual
survey called the triaa traffic safety
culture index um and 61% of IND of
respondents from across the country said
they that they admitted to going 10
miles an hour over in a residential area
and 50% admitted to doing 15 over um on
the highway while almost 40% of those
same respondents um thought it was
unsafe Behavior
um so I'm happy to share any of these
studies um you know we know
that it's just a major maor traffic
safety concern and I know State Police
and others can talk about what some of
these numbers are in New Hampshire but
this is this isn't a positive direction
we have increased crashes and fatalities
on our roads and I don't think this a a
positive step so I I ask you all to
oppose this bill I'm happy to answer any
questions thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here um do you do not your
but do all Insurance adjudicators do
they take in consideration when they're
setting the rates laws like
this thank you for the question I I do
not know the answer to that but I'd be
happy to um to look into that so just to
clarify you're asking do they look at
actually Comm yeah
follow actually both the uh okay I mean
I know they look at density they look at
uh incidents of accidents and so on I
just didn't know if they also look at
what the local laws are
saying thank you for the question I'm
happy to look into that and get back to
you thank you represent
sellers thank you Mr chair so you
mentioned um
the safe speed limit on the highways or
roadways and um I've seen in my lifetime
where they''re gone from like 70 or 65
down to 55 to just to save fuel and it's
the same roadway H that's one how do you
justify that and that's what in the same
aspect around certain areas of lakes and
and and local Town highways going
through local towns during the summer we
we sometimes lower the speed limit on
the same roadways the road hasn't
changed so how I'm just wondering what
do you think about that it's the same
road thank you for the question um yeah
I think it's a whole different thing
when you're talking about lowering
speeds because the speed limit is the
maximum um speed I I I know there's
there I'm not as familiar in the
engineering that goes to a minimum speed
I know you're hearing a bill right after
this to talk about lowering these speeds
and that's generally because in the
summer months there's increased
pedestrians and bicyclists um and I
don't know what that safe minimum speed
is but we know that you know for every
10 miles an hour over the crash sity
increases so it's much safer to be going
slower I don't know if I fully answer
your question I'd be happy to maybe chat
afterward but have to
answer yeah follow up thanks so even
even like around the lakes and stuff we
lower the speed by 10 miles an hour and
I'm saying and I was just asking the the
rep before you that well what happened
is we had adjusted that to 15% over
there you know so we've already lowered
it 10 miles an hour the the road is safe
for it so why can't you you say hey four
or five miles over a 30 mph speed limit
wouldn't be unreasonable that's all I'm
just trying to figure out would you
agree to that or
not thank you very much for the question
it's not something I've really thought
about but I happy to think about it a
little bit more and chat with you about
it um but it's an interesting concept
thank you
anybody else representative pandon thank
you Mr chair thank you for coming today
um hopefully I don't know if you can
answer this or not I don't know if
anyone here is here from dot uh my
experience I've worked uh as chairman of
infrastructure and nashor with multiple
City Engineers uh Traffic Engineers and
uh Highway dot but it's my understanding
that whether it's Urban compact or uh
class two three four highways speeds are
set and engineered depending on those
highway
conditions um do you concur with that
that there is a science behind setting
Ste speed
limits thank you very much for the
question um completely agree with you
Traffic Engineers do a ton of onsite
research lot lots of research to to go
into what that maximum speed limit
should be um but I think that question
could be better answered by a
representative from do thank thank you
thank you Mr chair which I do have a
pink card for as well as Department of
Safety uh any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh that being said next
up the chair
recognizes Michael O'Donnell from the
bill
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Michael odonnell I am the assistant
State traffic engineer at New Hampshire
do um I do have some written testimony
that I'll I'll pass around after this um
from commissioner Cass uh but I'd like
to just summarize it
um uh which is I narrowed it down to
Five Points uh that the commission
wanted to make um first of all the the
General Court established the
legislative intent of speed limit by
establishing statutory requirements for
um various roadway functions and also
authorize the commissioner of
transportation and any local
jurisdictions um to modify those values
on the basis of an engineering and
traffic
investigation uh the subject bill would
make those previous engineering and
traffic investigations obsolete by
increasing the reasonable and prudent
values uh by 10 m an hour which is
arbitrary um second Point um New
Hampshire dot uses a robust
research-based and data driven
engineering and traffic investigation
process uh to evaluate speed limits uh
through thorough collaboration with
local governing agencies and enforcement
personnel
um speed zones that are no longer
reflecting the reasonable and prudent
maximum speed uh can be reconsidered
through this process and the speed
limits reposted
accordingly um that could be increasing
the speed limit or reducing the speed
limit uh speed limit signing is the
appropriate means this is the third
Point made in the uh written testimony
speed limit signing is the appropriate
means to inform drivers of the Prima
fascist speed limit to expect drivers
visiting from other states and other
places to understand that New Hampshire
in New Hampshire the maximum credible
speed limit is 10 miles an hour over the
posted speed limit would seem
unreasonable to
us and
counterintuitive um fourth Point uh the
Federal Law requires that the sign
display the lawful maximum speed so
requiring um you know the speed limit to
be posted 10 miles an hour below it uh
would not allow New Hampshire to comply
with the federal
law uh fifth point and last Point uh one
of the most frequent comments we get uh
and requests received at the New
Hampshire
dot is involving traffic speeds and
speed limit concerns uh residents and
elected officials frequently ask for
Speed limit to be set arbitrarily 10 m
hour below the current posted speed uh
to incorporate a tolerance value um
however taking this action does not show
a similar speed reduction in the data
that we collect after doing um such a
thing uh the proposed bill would only
increase the pressure on the dot and
Municipal jurisdictions to further
reduce speed limits to account for the
new statutory tolerance
so uh thank you I can go into more
detail if you like and it sounded like
questions thank you sir and you did have
written testimony you said yes I can
pass that around fantastic any questions
from the committee I see one from
representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman Mr odonnell
yes um I I tried to look at the fiscal
note and it does it has z0000 Z so it's
not particularly helpful but is it a far
leap to suggest that there will be costs
associated with the do having to change
any signs or is it uh in order to be in
compliance with federal law or not um
the uh thank you uh the the signs are
currently in compliance with federal
law
um so if this bill passes we can't meet
the federal law because we would always
have to post 10 miles an hour below the
speed limit and um Federal Law requires
that we post the speed limit for for
is representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Odon for
taking my question you mentioned in your
testimony that there's a process that
someone can go through to get the speed
limits reconsidered can you speak about
that process yeah yes uh thank you uh
the basic process would be that we would
we would want to start it off by working
with Municipal officials um to make sure
that you know rather than just one
person who wants people to go slower in
front of their
driveway um you know as you pass their
house you know isn't the only voice in
the room so we we usually like to go to
the you know the town legisl or the town
uh executive body whether it be it's
Board of Selectmen or or whoever it
might be to to try to gauge the support
for it uh we try to let people know that
you know once there is an engineering in
traffic investigation that becomes a
document of public record um so if the
engineering in traffic
investigation concludes that the speed
limit should be higher than it is um
that is a discoverable document that
could be presented in court um so if you
had a situation where we were
recommending a speed limit 10 miles an
hour greater than what is posted now and
the people calling us really wanted it
10 miles an hour
lower um you know that that could get
somebody out of a ticket potentially
that they that they find that document
but uh once we've gone through that
discussion uh we start data collection
we have a number of resources available
to us we have uh big data so to speak
probe data um that measures the speed of
the traffic flow um basically using
connected Vehicles cell phones uh things
like that and uh we we analyze that data
um we identify you know the 85th
percentile speed is what's commonly
known as the reasonable uh speed uh
reasonable and prudent speed we look at
crash data we look at uh items that
would consider the the character of the
roadway like density of driveway
presence or absence of pedestrian
traffic um you know and then we we use a
a program called us limits 2 um which uh
basically feed all that data into it and
it uses a a research-based
process um it's used in in many states
uh in addition to New Hampshire and it
basically spits out the recommended
speed limit um we are required Now by
federal law to set the speed limit
within 5 miles an hour of that
recommendation uh based on the 85th
percentile um you there are changes in
the works
um I guess I won't speak to that because
they haven't happened yet uh but there
is a lot of continuing research going on
limit I've got one if you don't mind
just to clarify everything you said for
to remain federally compliant we would
have to make new signs throughout the
state that are 10 miles an hour below
what we currently have is that what you
said
um no it's if I said that I'm sorry
that's not what I meant uh the Federal
Law requires that the speed limit be
posted on the
sign so if if we have a we we would
never be able to meet that if this bill
passes we would be out of federal
compliance
that that's my point
so we're If This Were to pass the speed
limit would be 10 miles hour above
what's posted right
so how let me let me let me get away
from that one what happens if we're not
federally compliant um what does that
mean they they could um penalize us with
our federal funding um I haven't known
it to happen in our State uh I do know
of cases where it's happened in New York
state um but I have not seen it happen
here um but that would be like our our
funding under the transportation bill
which New Hampshire dot programs a lot
of federal money to do projects around
the
state thank you any other questions from
the committee and keep in mind we have
uh Department of Safety in the queue did
I see your hand representative
Jes yes thank you Mr chair I'll make
make this quick um I'm going to show my
age uh and I don't expect an answer
right now but uh back in the 70s when we
had an energy crisis the speed limits
were lower 10 miles per
hour were was there less traffic
incidents back then and you don't have
to answer that now yeah I don't I don't
have that answer
now thank you representative
sellers uh thank you Mr chair and
apologize but going back to your
question uh Mr chair is if it has to be
stated on the sign does it have to be
stated in specific size I mean could it
be like uh two point you know print or
something like that yeah that um thanks
for the question the the uh federal laws
do require that it be a certain size for
type yeah follow thank you and and
federal law does that only apply to the
interstate or to State highways as well
uh thanks the um federal law applies to
all roadways public or private that are
open to public travel so that could even
be a parking lot for a business that's
public representative pland pland sorry
thank you Mr a tough one good enough
yeah three syllables but good job to
continue uh on representative s's
position or questions um I know for
non-moving violation a non-moving uh
traffic light stop sign so on there's a
the mcds that which are a guidelin and
you mentioned federal laws and such is
there variation on moving violations or
or speed limits and uh how speed limits
are are uh posted on certain grade roads
and Road densities is there a federal
guideline like the mcds from for Speed
and moving
violations um so thanks if I'm
understanding the question um you know
the the moving violations and how things
are enforced is not covered in the mutcd
there may be a document that department
of safety works with
um if I could clarify Mr chair yeah
follow up um for non-moving we've got
the mcds what I'm asking is for for
moving violations I.E setting speed
limits are there federal guidelines that
denot certain class highways certain
densities that the speed limits need to
be with these Within These
parameters um yes I think I understand
so the the mutcd is the federal law I
was referencing and yes uh the mutcd
does include guidelines for setting
speed limit um there are no statutory
type requirements like our state has in
federal law um that would say you know
for an interstate it it be this or or
that um you know those are those are
covered under our current uh speed limit
law in New Hampshire um but the
mutcd uh there is a code of federal
regulations associated with that that
adopts it as federal law uh currently um
and we are between mut tcds at the
moment the 2009 version is what we're
using in New Hampshire and the 2009
version is what requires that the speed
limit be set within 5 miles an hour of
the 85th percentile speed perfect thank
you thank you Mr
chair seeing no other questions thank
chair
uh next
up chair recognize Chris Storm from the
Hampshire State Police uh in opposition
welcome
I'll lead off by the one that I know
everybody's waiting for at what point at
what speed on average on Interstate 93
posted 65 miles an hour will you
them I'm sorry can I get you to turn
your mic too please that's a great
question representative um the answer is
I can't answer that specifically due to
the fact that it is a a discretionary
thing amongst any law enforcement
officer that's out there um are people
getting stopped for 66 and a 65 I don't
believe so are they being ticketed for
that I don't believe so um I'm sure if
we looked at the the data that comes in
through the office of Highway Safety we
could probably tell you um what the
majority of tickets that are coming um
that are coming into that office are but
again that's discretionary towards the
uh the trooper the deputy the officer to
actually be allowed to lower that on the
side of the road too and not necessarily
give that individual the actual fine for
the speed that they're actually going
and actually come down that's the
discretion of that particular officer
Deputy or uh
Trooper thank you sir fair enough any
other questions from the committee
representative
sellers thank you on that note could you
could we get that data as far as the
high and low speeds that they have
pulled people over for do you have that
you said the actual the um I could
probably provide that from the
Department of Safety I probably um that
would be a DMV question for as far as um
they are part of the Department of
Safety but as far as the state police go
go we can probably provide you with
that thank you any other questions from
the
committee sorry yes you're on TV one day
and look at this representative
sellers trying to use the right words um
thank you Mr chair I've noticed like in
I've traveled through the states and
some states have uh speed limits uh even
up to 80 miles an hour um under the
federal rules that we have here if I'm
not sure you're aware of them is that do
they give us a range for the state or in
each highway I mean I don't that's what
I'm trying to figure out representative
um great question I don't know the
answer to that what I can tell you in
the Hampshire we do have the absolute
speed limit right so we have that 65
mile and then anything north of exit 17
on i93 you have the maximum allowable
speed limit or is 70 miles an hour so
anything posted above that or anybody
allowable go any higher than that is
according right now to 26560 our law is
against the law to go anything more than
70 miles an hour
further questions representative ve
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I think it was
suggested in past testimony for other
bills for another bill that the courts
don't want to see anybody objecting to a
ticket unless it's at least 10 miles an
hour over or 15 miles an hour over do
you have difficulty Prosecuting
violations that are less than 10 miles
an hour over or within any range
of violation that's a great question I
actually don't I don't know the answer
to that what I can tell you with being
in court for 20s something years that um
as long as we've proven our case I've
never really had an issue with a
speeding ticket um you know obviously
for the right reasons u i and I don't
think I've ever seen anybody really have
any um issues um bringing up to the
judge what they what they actually saw
what they observed and and the reasons
for which they stopped that
vehicle okay seeing no other questions
thank you very
much and final speaker that I have
signed up Steve zck uh
morning good morning uh I here in
support of the bill uh I just want to
encourage everybody on this committee to
check out a uh documentary about how
speed limits are Set uh and how CH up uh
increasing them could actually improve
safety the uh title of the documentary
it's in two parts it's called Uh speed
kills your pocketbook uh it's available
free on YouTube and uh I linked to it
and uh submitted uh written testimony
through the web portal so uh I hope
everybody checks it out um the other
thing is I don't necessarily think that
speed limits are set properly to the
85th percentile because if you've ever
been driving along in a rural New
Hampshire town at 11: you know late late
at night and had a cop behind you
tailgating you
and you set your cruise control exactly
to the speed limit it's very
nerve-wracking and it seems like it's
suspicious to them that you're going the
speed limit and I've gotten pulled over
for going exactly the speed limit so
that's not a reason they make something
up but I think speed limit should
probably be set more to an 85th
percentile I know that's not exactly the
point of this bill but I think it's a
step in the right direction uh to EV
that'll help evaluate what
people really would go if they were able
to go at the uh speed they find it's
proper um and I think this bill would uh
help alleviate some of the really
uh unnecessarily stripped speed lims in
some small areas
so thank you very much we take any
questions or uh if anyone has any
questions actually I don't see any so
thank you again very much
uh that's the last person I have signed
up to speak um so I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
1063 just give us a few moments to reset
and we'll move
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing
being 10:06 on House Bill 1550
authorizing municipalities to reduce
speed limits seasonally uh chair
recognizes representative eel uh the
prime sponsor good morning welcome to
Transportation thank you very much Mr
chair um for the record my name is uh
Karen eel and I represent marac district
7 which is New London and
Newbury um I'm here uh introducing HB
1550 which is um um in large part A
reintroduction of a bill um I believe it
was HB 93 that was tabled last year um
by the house and there were some
concerns expressed about the bill which
I hope in this version of the bill um
I've been able to answer with a couple
of tweaks to the um to the
language so I did give you um a copy of
my testimony um which outlines basically
the situation I think it's a pretty
simple um simple concept um I also just
really want to point out to you that
this is uh very much a bipartisan Bill
we have a full compliment of Democrats
and Republicans on um in the house and
in the Senate so I actually consider
this a nonpartisan um piece of
legislation which is nice um so the bill
uh would permit the seasonal reduction
of speed limits to 20 20 M an hour once
in uh 4 month period and the town can
decide on its own if it would like to
make this reduction or um a citizen uh
group of 10 people could provide a
petition to the town um I just want to
clarify that if the um town does get a
petition requested a reduction of a
speed limit there's actually there's
absolutely no responsibility on the part
of the town to do that reduction it just
has a responsibility to assess the
requests of its citizens in a way that
it would uh you know acknowledge the
request of any um citizen group um the
change that I made in this this time and
I have worked with the Department of
Transport ation which will'll be
speaking to the bill later I did insert
in in the bill the requirement that um
to make the change in the um speed limit
the town governing body would have to do
it on the basis of an engineering and a
traffic
investigation this sort of parallels the
process that the state does when it's
assessing um speed limits um and and the
other thing uh I changed and I just
really wanted to clarify because I think
there was some um uh misunderstanding
about this last
year there is no responsibility to
change the speed limit just because they
get a citizen petition it just triggers
a conversation about whether or not to
do it um
the changes that I'm seeking through
this bill um are changes that would
parallel The Authority in a town to that
that's already granted for the state on
seasonally congested roads and it seems
to me from a local control standpoint
and from a taxpayer standpoint and a
town Safety standpoint that a town um
really should be given the authority to
have as many tools as it can logically
have in its toolbox to makes it make its
roads as safe as they can um as they can
be and so the situation actually arose
in my town where we have um we have many
lakes just in our town but there's one
in particular that's incredibly popular
for
Walkers uh people pushing strollers dog
walkers bikers I mean you name it and
the road gets it's you know a lot of us
uh we still have these small Meandering
roads that are immediately by um a water
body they get really congested and
they're also frequently through roads
and so um you know there have been many
circumstances where the pedestrians
perhaps aren't as cautious as they uh
could be when they're walking and it's
just really helpful for the town to be
able to assess the situation and reduce
the speed limit to 20 M an hour if it
deems um that that makes sense along
with using other tools that it has um
the bill is supported by the New
Hampshire Municipal
Association um I know they had
anticipated being here today but I heard
they had something like 40 bills or some
and he's here oh good
he's here all right I won't talk about
the municipal Association then
um uh the only other thing I wanted to
add here is I did provide you uh with a
copy of a letter and support from our
town manager and um you know of course
she collaborates with our police chief
and this is something that the police
chief is really interested in
accomplishing um I know that there have
been discussions about doing something
along these lines for several years it's
something that the towns really really
would appreciate um the authority to do
under state law to reduce it seasonally
and um I hope that with the changes that
I've made this time the committee um
would agree that that this makes sense
um for our towns and I guess uh that's
all I really have to say the only other
thing I would add is I just want to also
made clear that this can be an annual
assessment by the town there's
absolutely no responsibility by the town
to do it any more than once and if they
do you know if they reduce the speed
limit for the 4mon period they don't
think it works or whatever they they
don't have to do it again but at least
they would be given the option so with
that um I'd be happy to answer any
questions you might have
thank you very much questions from the
committee representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question you mentioned that the petition
just triggers a
conversation so can you can you kind of
walk us through like some someone does a
petition or a group does a petition how
long would it take from petition to the
point of it being
changed I mean I suppose that would I I
haven't got a timeline in here again I
paralleled the uh State process and
there is somebody here from the state
who could maybe talk about this but I
would think that if a petition was
brought in in May and the folks or April
and the folks were really hoping to have
the four-month period instituted you
know for the summer and maybe into the
fall because the congestion is easily as
difficult in the fall as it is during
the summer um you know uh Selectmen tend
to meet uh weekly or bi-weekly and I'm
around any other questions from the
committee representative sers thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh you said it's newon you're
representing right and Newbery and
Newbury
um I guess my question is is around the
data how many accidents do you have
around the Lakes area do you have that
data you can give to us I don't have
actual data for you I mean I I'm sure it
could be obtained but you know it's
local data as as opposed to um something
that probably the state keeps track of I
mean we have someone here from the
municipal Association we have somebody
here from from do and I think anyone uh
could understand that it can be
incredibly difficult uh during congested
Seasons to maintain uh you know the safe
roads I mean you know has somebody
actually been hit and killed or
something I you know I can't tell you
exactly the
circumstances I know one time I was
doing 20 mil an hour or less and I came
around a corner in one of our lakes and
there was a very happy family with their
dog just strung out right across the
road and then another dog came leaping
out and um you know if I hadn't been
going the speed that I was going it
could have been a challenging situation
so I I really think this would be
helpful if the committee would consider
sporting
it representative foot thank you Mr
chair thank you representative I'm not
sure if you can answer this enough but
in the bill here it says the the
municipality will be um they would be
receiving the cost of the signage for
for the changes correct so there's no
cost to be born by the state my question
would be
if you you know let's say somebody who
goes up seasonally to this to the lake
area and drives around and last time
they were up there it was 30 miles an
hour and they're not paying attention
just the foliage or whatnot and they
thinking 30 miles an hour would there be
any other additional signage requirement
to kind like a pre-s signage like hey
just you know the speed changes in X
miles around this facility or because
people can get caught up in that muscle
memory um you know I think we frequently
have situations where there are digital
signs that are put up on the side of the
road and um I know in my town if there's
a situation that arises even if it's
voting or if it's a winter storm or
whatever or you see it on the side of a
of a state highway there's notifications
of a Slowdown ahead and so I think um
you know they would put some sort of
signage up to indicate and I guess the
only other thing I would say is that you
know drivers also have responsibilities
to pay attention to the road and they're
frequently um speed changes on any road
that you go along and you have to be
alert so um as much as there's a
responsibility for signage I think
there's always a continuing
responsibility on the part of the driver
to be aware of their
surroundings any other questions
represent
thank you Mr chairman thank you for take
my question um since there is provision
in the law currently for uh seasonal
speed limit adjustments how does your
bill make it better um there is a
provision in state law that allows the
state upon petition to reduce the speed
limit to 20 miles an hour the problem is
there is no parallel Authority for towns
to do the same thing so the state in
this case has an authority that the
towns do not and they don't have the
authority on their own
roads oh that's how it makes it better
to answer your question go ahead follow
up um as a followup uh are there any
particular roads that uh might not be
available uh certain highways like if a
numbered Highway way goes through your
town or something like that is that well
this
wouldn't this would only apply to town
roads so if there was um someone that or
if a municipality wanted to request the
state to reduce the speed limit on a
state road they could do that um and
then it would be up to the state on
whether or not they wanted to do it I
mean frankly the situation we've got
right now and I have it in my town I
have a state state road that goes around
one part of the lake and I have a Town
Road that is on the other part of the
lake and the state could reduce the
speed limit to 20 miles an hour for the
same four-month period I mean this
language is virtually identical to what
to the state statute that allows states
to do this anyway the state could uh
reduce the speed limit to 20 miles an
hour but the town couldn't and
so I mean for me just from a standpoint
of of local control um you know these
people the towns pay for the roads they
use the roads the most they Patrol the
roads they're directly responsibility
responsible for the safety of the roads
and they currently don't have this tool
to reduce the speed limit to try to keep
the road safe in their town
and I was grow I grew up in Austin I'm a
New Hampshire native I'm like if the
state can do this I just really think
too uh any other questions from the
committee uh I've got one I'll say for
the Department of Transportation but the
other one I have for you uh if 10
residents of a
municipality um sign a petition is there
and a reading through it now is there
any guarantee or of how the hearing
process uh May work in the town uh
because perhaps 10 people want it
lowered but maybe the rest of the Town
doesn't um well you know in in my town
um we have Selectmen and the Selectmen
would consider it at a public meeting at
a public hearing and notice goes into
the newspaper and all the other ways in
uh in which public hearings are noticed
and you know people would have the
opportunity to come and speak their
minds
I one thing I would say Mr chair is that
I wanted to at least have 10 people um
sign the petition because I didn't feel
that one or two people I just didn't
feel that was enough I mean I felt like
you should have some sort of consensus
among a certain number of people um to
bring this forward to ensure that it's a
it's a situation worthy of
consideration thank you
seeing
no further questions representative foot
thank you Mr chair F thank you
representative um so in this bill is it
limited to a certain number of streets
per Community or can they just to a
blanket the whole Community as a whole
so because of seasonal um increase where
summer winter
whatnot or is it limited to an isolated
area it says well what this says on any
part part of a highway SE system that is
seasonally congested so the the um I
mean as I understand it the way the
state works I mean they look at a
particular part of the road and but you
know if the if the town of Tuftonboro
wanted to reduce it seasonally to to um
to 20 miles an hour I suppose they could
I don't I just don't think that that
would
happen seeing no further questions thank
you very
much uh next up chair recognizes
representative Maki uh in support of the
bill looking for three
morning um thank you Mr chairman
esteemed members of
Transportation um for the record my name
is uh Mark mcon I represent the good
people of Carol District 8 um I'm from I
live in the town of freedom on Lake and
my member towns Effingham
Freedom
um and others all border that body of
water town of Madison borders uh another
Lake being Silver Lake and I have many
of these locations as you drive around
my district where um 40 years ago uh
when beaches were established by towns
and there wasn't a lot of room for a
beach then they just cleared places to
the side of the rideway to
park and the people that live in those
areas also many times have homes that
are across the street and they their
access to their boat and so forth is
across the street in particular I have a
a road Plains Road uh that runs from um
Tamworth into Madison it's a state
shared Road uh residents for years have
been trying to find some way of relief
seasonally to slow down that traffic as
it passes by um I have um I have a state
highway that runs through the town of
Tamworth um through a village in South
Tamworth that was always at 35 miles an
hour and then one day a person from the
Department decided that that didn't make
sense and started the proc process and
increase the speed to 45 M an hour had
notified the U the town official the
police department and no one had
responded and the speed limit moved up
to that the people in that short Village
District as you all know when you drive
there's usually a 10 m hour uh variance
on when we're going to stop uh traffic
from moving through and they were
totally alarmed Med over the process
it's going to take uh Community
involvement uh the Lakes Region Planning
Commission and probably a year or two
years to bring those people in do back
to the table to see if we can have a
reduction in speed limit in the people
in in
um in Madison on this Silver Lake
stretch of road I'm talking to they're
repeatedly asking how can we do this uh
the question on on uh signage that's out
there before and after uh that stretch
of road and many of these stretch of
roads routinely within 10 miles will
move up 10 10 miles per hour higher or
lower so forth so I I support this uh
this
proposal um I think it's something that
U is to the benefit of of my small towns
I don't have cities I have I have towns
populations of 2 to 5,000 th000 people
and I think this is something that that
uh will provide uh safety uh to my
little towns and let the Selectmen
decide if it's something they want to
move forward with or not move forward
and then it might also then give energy
on some of those State highways where I
have issues once this is put in uh that
might open up a conversation that'll be
easier to have with that I Happ to take
questions if there are sir thank you
very much any questions from the
committee let letting you off the hook
recognizes and this is from a
professional Noah
Gres representing the Hampshire
Municipal Association gra for the
municipal Association I apologize for my
handwriting and uh in support of the
bill looking for a couple of minutes yes
please um so the municipal Association
does support this bill um I understand
that the same idea has come before the
the committee several times before we
think this year it is very narrowly
targeted to address the specific problem
that we've heard from Members about um
we have as you've already heard today
numerous communities that have you know
either beaches across the street from
parking lots or for some reason or other
uh very congested local Road
particularly around you know bodies of
water um around you know winter sports
areas uh things of that nature um and
they're only congested seasonally um
we've heard from local police
departments from local public works
departments that there are situations
that don't always result in accidents
but they are stationing police out there
more frequently because they want to you
know when somebody sees a police car
generally they slow down although uh
that's not always the case but they
usually slow down because they expect
something is happening um and keep a
little bit closer eye on the road um and
so municipalities have been trying to
mitigate this to some extent but it
isn't isn't enough um and so what they
would like to do is seasonally reduce
that speed limit because they think that
the that would assist them in avoiding
um incidents where there may be injuries
there may be property damage involved um
I live in the city of conquer I can
speak personally there are several
streets um that are seasonally congested
um unfortunately my car has been the
victim of uh a avoidance of a uh
accident with a person instead was my
car was the chosen Target um had
everyone been driving slower that would
have been avoided um but nevertheless um
uh it is a local option that we think is
really important really clearly targeted
towards um allowing me to I alties the
local level to use their local knowledge
of the the their Road system and apply
that in the manner that best suits their
their residents happy to take any
questions that the committee committee
may have thank you any questions from
the committee seeing then thank you
again uh representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman uh just a
quick question um and I maybe I should
have asked the sponsor but I know you're
you're up on this how do you define
seasonal like if if there's a onewe bike
week is that considered a season if
somebody has a pond hockey tournament
over a weekend is that a season or does
it have to be a summer
season so the or a winter season the
intent here is for really a I think a
summer weekend not not a summer or
winter or fall something like that up to
a 4month period not not a week weekend
um a weekend event typically has uh you
know additional police presence they
often have detail work out there um to
control traffic um and that's a
temporary uh a temporary situation it's
a lot more difficult to manage traffic
over a two three four month period as
people are visiting the lake um because
you simply can't stretch your Police
Department in that manner for that long
of a Time thank you Mr chairman forther
questions see
representative
plon thank you just very quick my only
concern with this and I'm looking for
your opinion is uh say a rapid speed
drop it's going from say more than 10
miles an hour from a 30 to 20 I think is
reasonable but if you've got a 35 or
even possibly a 45 mph going to 20
should there be something legislatively
to pre-warn at a certain distance notice
you know 100 yard speed drops to 20 mil
an hour that's about my concern with
this any recommendations there if that's
an amendment that the committee wants to
have I wouldn't have any objection to
that um we're just trying to make things
safer certainly if there's you know
we've all seen on the side of the road
State Police ahead type thing um if
that's you if if the committee believes
that would that would benefit the
community and help uh reduce any uh any
incidents of harm to anyone or property
that's certainly something we would we
would support thank you thank you Mr
chair further
questions seeing done thank you very
much thank you and representative plon
that that question probably best served
for the Department of Transportation who
is coming
up uh as a matter of fact coming up next
Sher recognizes Michael O'Donald from
the New Hampshire Department of
Transportation not taking a position on
the bill from what I can
again all right thank you Mr chairman
and members of committee for the record
my name is Michael odonnell I am the
assistant State traffic engineer at New
Hampshire
do um I do have written testimony again
from uh commissioner Cass and uh we um
do take a position on this in support of
this bill um sorry I didn't mark that on
my on my card
um um
sure um so basically in the 15
legislative session a bill passed to
allow seasonal speed limits on state
highways that were seasonally congested
by pedestrian and bicycle traffic um
26562 um some communities uh have taken
advantage of this and uh we have
evaluated and allowed them to post
seasonal speed limit reductions uh most
of these are around lakes and um you
know as as was pointed out um some Lakes
have state maintained and owned uh class
two roadways along their Frontage and
others have class five locally
maintained roads along their Frontage
some have a combination of both so you
could be driving around the lake on a
Class 2 state road with a seasonal speed
limit and then you turn a corner to
continue your journey around the lake
and you're now on a class five locally
maintained Road and as the law is
written now they do not have the
authority to post a seasonal speed speed
limit on their Road um so this bill
would would offer that level of
consistency um in the area uh oftentimes
motorists don't know whose jurisdiction
they're in whether they're on a state
road or a local Road especially a
non-numbered state road and we we do
have many of those um so we would uh
support this bill to give the
municipalities the authority to
seasonally reduce speed limits on their
roads uh just as the state has the
authority to do it on our roads thank
you thank you very much I'm going to
lead off with a couple of quick
questions um the speed limits on the
municipally posted class five roads as
you say
um are those speed limits because I'm
looking at lines 13 14 that even with a
petition the engineering and traffic
investigation will take place so speed
limits that are currently there are
those engineered and and trafficly
investigated if you
will I I find often times
not um that's fine I just didn't want to
see looking at it at the beginning you
would think that there would be no no
difference uh in the recommendation if
they were both investigated so fair
enough any other questions from the
committee representative V thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um how effective are these I
mean I think the motivation is to reduce
police patrols but how effective is just
dropping the speed limit without some
other form of friction like a police
patrol or barriers or something like
thanks for the question um we've found
that there's no practical difference in
operating speeds resulting from the
seasonal speed limits
um you know we can detect in the data
slight
reductions um I think the the largest
benefit has been to the municipalities
and the
citizens feeling like they can do
something about speed uh and I have
heard very positive things from the
towns and individual
citizens on that matter thanks thank you
did I see representative SES thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr odonnell um I
just want to clarify a point that was
raised earlier my understanding is that
this
bill would allow speed limits to go down
to 20 but does not necessarily require
that they go down to 20 if it's a 35 M
hour speed limit the town may wish to do
only 30 or
25 is that am I reading this correctly
yes I believe you are um we've done that
on the state system where um you know
for example the town requested a 10 m
hour reduction on the state road and the
state found five miles an hour to be
more appropriate thank
you representative
Landon thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Odon again to repeat a question I
asked earlier um would you how do you
feel about an area where the road is uh
the speed reduction would say is more
than 10 miles an hour should there be a
prior notice um say you know 100 yards
in advance that you know speed limits
going from 45 to 20 that's one question
what's your opinion on that sir um thank
you for the question uh my my opinion is
I'm not issued an opinion I follow the
mutcd which does require that type of
signage that you mentioned perfect thank
you if I may continue next question
follow up um next question is um many uh
uh towns uh when entering the town there
they they post uh basically the state
law speed limit throughout the town if
unposted 30 miles an hour do you foresee
this as an opportunity for a town when
they're having a seasonal event for a
month or two just post for the entire
town speed limit reduced to 20 miles an
hour during the month of August is that
is that feasible I I do not see that as
a possibility um because this this
references the seasonal um congestion by
pedestrians and
bicyclists so we're thinking you know
maybe uh May 15 to September 15th or
Memorial Day to Labor Day that's what
we've been looking at at the state as a
season uh you know could be the fall if
it's uh you know foliage season Etc
thank you a final comment we're going to
move on um you know what quickly okay
one more yeah real quick so in other
words what you're saying is that these
streets should the the board their
selected board uh vote on this they
would be each individually
posted yes that that would be the intent
thank
you uh anybody else from the committee I
have one more if you don't mind
um nothing personal the but these bills
and I've seen many of these efforts for
20 miles an hour over the years and and
the words of uh Mr Lambert I think you
who you replaced many years ago before
this committee when he said 20 miles an
hour is painfully
slow and so I don't have a problem with
with u with uh reduced speed limits when
it's needed but the problem with these
bills is that that's only when the
people are present even though as I
heard earlier it's the pedestrians that
aren't paying attention that's actually
spawning
this have you seen or is any other
mechanism in statute that would allow
for speed limit change to be for certain
hours of the day and the reason I ask is
because if there's no people or are no
people present we are still going to be
stuck with the 20 M hour painfully
slow I I don't know that I have a
complete answer on that although I do
feel like the
mutcd has Night speed limits they have
uh black signs for for night uh we don't
haven't done that in New Hampshire uh to
my knowledge um and i' I've looked a lot
of speed limits I worked closely with
with Bill Lambert for a number of years
um and still still uh talked to him
quite a bit in his position as safety
administrator thank you very much
thank you seeing no other questions
thank you again uh that's last person I
have signed up to speak on House Bill
1550 so I'll close the public hearing uh
a few minutes to reset we will
be few minutes behind going into house
bille
KB at 10:43 I'm going to open up the uh
public hearing on H Bill
1403 relative to temporary vehicle
emission control equipment in
introducing the
bill uh it will just be representative
sellers thank you Mr chair uh
representative cell is Grafton district
18 I'm just here to introduce a bill
booked thank
sellers
chair I like to call up Rebecca hour and
Jessica
Wilcox from the new New Hampshire
Department of ir Environmental
Services doesn't really say if you
support or oppose the bill and asking
minutes Rebecca erer Department of
Environmental Services and with me is
Jessica Wilcox the head of our mobile
sources section uh Dees does not take a
position on this bill but wanted to make
the committee aware of some uh
requirements that are apply to the state
of New
Hampshire uh from the Federal
Environmental Protection Agency so Motor
Vehicles are our primary source of air
pollution in the state of New Hampshire
and while New Hampshire is in attainment
with all of our federal air quality
standards at the moment we were not um
as little as you know eight years ago I
believe
and so
uh trying to remember exactly when we
implemented the requirement for onboard
diagnostics testings of Motor Vehicles
but it was it was um quite some time ago
we've gone through several rural
revisions with Department of Safety to
streamline the program and make sure
that uh that it is um as sort of
non-intrusive as possible our latest
change to the to the state rules were
submitted to EPA
about 24 months ago and I think just
last month or the beginning of this
month we finally received Federal
approval of those of those new rules so
we can Now operate by the new rules um
so the point here being that we can
change the rules uh but it takes time
and it cannot be done in 60 days to
number one revise the state rules but
but more importantly to have Federal
approval by the um Environmental prot
Protection Agency absent that Federal
approval should EPA be so inclined they
could theoretically come in and enforce
our previous rules on the state of New
Hampshire or uh you know simply find the
state to be in non-compliance with our
state implementation plan which could
risk Federal
funding so again you know Dees um is is
open to discussing changes to the rules
but the 60-day time period on this um is
going to be uh way too short for us to
do this in in a way that would be
acceptable by our governor governing
Federal agency um the other point that I
wanted to make is that Federal rules
have changed since our our program was
designed and again we just recently got
a sort of a reauthorization under our
revised
rules but recently the federal
government has adopted additional rul
making that requires uh
new sort of states that are newly coming
into non attainment and having to
implement onboard diagnostics testing or
other vehicle emission programs to also
include onroad testing of vehicles so
whether that uh is um you know driveby
testing because there are sort of laser
gun type things that can that can take
um measur of tailpipe emissions or
whether it's pulling random cars over on
the side of the road and and requiring
roadside testing of these to make sure
they're in
compliance uh that is a a current
requirement of the federal rules if we
had to revise our state rules right now
it is entirely possible that EPA would
require New Hampshire to implement that
portion of the federal program as
well I'm happy to take any
questions thank you so much any
I actually have one uh you mentioned the
60 days if I understand you
correctly your concern is not moving the
moving the actual the waiver from 60 to
90 days your concern is more of 60 days
if this bill passes it gets instituted
within 60 days that I hear you
correcting the concern um so the the
bill would
change the 60 days to 90 days we
currently have Federal approval for that
60-day because the the rules that
implement this um the department of
safety rules that implement this program
are part of our federally approved State
imp implementation plan so anytime they
update their rules we have to go through
this entire process to get um the final
okay from Environmental Protection
Agency so they would need the time to
change their rules and we would need the
time to then uh subsequently submit
those rules to EPA for approval and
incorporation into our state
implementation plan so so that's the
part of it but also because because the
federal requirements have become more
stringent um EPA could also uh reject
our proposed amendment and and say you
need to you know if you're going to
change your existing authorization you
need to come all the way up to full
compliance with the federal rules which
again now would require some level of of
onroad
testing representative Coker thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question do do you know approximately
how much money is like I guess like like
Federal funding would be at stake if we
fall out of
compliance I I can't give you a dollar
amount um I will say that almost the
entirety of the Department of
Environmental Services is is
funded or quite a bit of it is funded
through the Environmental Protection
Agency
funding
um uh some do programs could be at risk
and I'm trying to think if Department of
Safety could be at risk as well um okay
I I I really can't answer that do you
know like anybody that might know how
just how much total funding could be on
the line like we can certainly take the
question back and and see if we can get
an answer awesome thank you
yep any other questions from the
you well I have no other further cards
on on this bill so I guess that will
on
um chair I like to recognize uh Steve
Zac who uh supports the bill um my name
is Steve zanic I'm from Manchester uh I
do support the bill uh and one of the
reasons I support the bill is sometimes
uh basically the whole emissions program
is based on uh computer checks
internally to the car there's no
tailpipe emissions checks anymore so
your car could probably be running
completely fine not polluting but you
know One sensor is acting up you know
and it could be an intermittent issue
maybe there's a broken wire somewhere
and it's just really hard to
diagnose um it could I've seen people
spend thousands trying to get the check
wallet light to turn off on their car um
and uh even if the even if the solution
to the check engine light is is very
obvious and can be fixed immediately um
even once you you know replace the
sensor or fix the wire or whatever is
wrong with it um and you reset the code
you still have to drive several drive
cycles um to make the uh car OBD ready
um and uh depending on your driving
conditions and stuff it could take weeks
for it to go to um uh to OBD ready mode
sometimes and sometimes if it's like an
intermittent issue you might think it's
fixed and it's not um so I do support
giving people more time to try to
troubleshoot and fix the issue uh the
other thing I would really recommend and
like to see is um if there is a
um if there was an alternative to the
OBD check for testing emissions where if
you think you're your car is fine but
yeah there's a check engine LI or it's
not going in OBD Readiness mode or
whatever the issue may be that maybe you
can bring your car somewhere else that
has an old school tailpipe sniffer that
actually checks the emissions of the
vehicle rather than just relying solely
on the OBD um there was an article in
the Boston Globe over the summer about a
guy from Massachusetts who bought a uh
Chevy brand new Chevy from a dealership
in nashaa um and the check engine light
came on and General Motors still well at
least as of the time of the article in
the summer never had a fix for him and
it was going on months and months and uh
he couldn't get his Massachusetts
inspection sticker because of this check
engine light and maybe if there was some
kind of alternative program for him to
get an actual tailpipe sniff or whatever
uh they could
have at least gotten him as sticker so
he can continue to drive the the car and
you know maybe for in his case there
might have been some lemon law or
something to to to go fall back on but
that could take months to go through
court or whatever it would have to go
through so um I do think that you know
sometimes things aren't cut and dry and
they're not and problems aren't
obviously quickly
fixed thank you any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um in your experience how how often is
is the car operating um to parameters
but yet the light is on
um I I don't know how often that happens
but I've seen it happen uh I like I'm
not a professional mechanic but you know
I I work on my my own cars my family's
cars uh friends Cars uh you know and
sometimes you know I've seen people
spend
you know th sometimes thousands of
dollars chasing an issue um and it's you
know and sometimes it's so weird and
intermittent that causes the issue so uh
now they don't do tailpipe sniffing
anymore so I mean technically
something's wrong if the check engine
lights um on but that doesn't
polluting any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank
you okay with that I don't have any
cards so I'm going to close the hearing
on
1403 our next bill will be HP 1637 in
minutes
session
you
oh
y
for
okay it be at 11 o'clock I'm going to
open up the public hearing on HP
1637 relative to reducing requirements
for vehicle inspection the prime sponsor
is not here so representative Coker will
be introducing the
Bill thank you Mr chairman um so HB 1637
is a um act to reduce requirements for
vehicle inspections I'm kind of doing a
uh a I guess courtesy introduction on it
uh one aspect of the bill I like is it
looks like it decouples
the
um basically instead of having the
sticker be tied to your birth month it's
tied to when it was inspected so that's
the aspect of the bill that I like but
other than that uh I'll take any
questions but probably not
really
Coker do do we have other other pin
cards for this Bill yes okay
thanks chair like to recognize Rebecca
oler and
Jessica wer
WLX from the New Hampshire Department of
vental Services do not say you support
or oh there's the prime I'll give hello
hello again Rebecca erer Jessica Wilcox
um this is is pretty much the same
points as the previous bill in that this
would change um the RSA that uh that has
been adopted under our federally
approved State implementation plan
therefore we would have to submit and
get EPA get Federal approval of a new
state implementation plan in addition
this would um because it would reduce
five years worths of vehicles um and the
oldest would and typically the most the
highest polluting Vehicles because
things do degrade after time we would be
the state of new hire would be required
to implement measures that would make up
for those additional emissions that
would come from the Transportation
sector by implementing um uh rules on
some other portion of our of our SE of
our economy most likely the business
sector because when U businesses are the
second largest source of air pollution
in New Hampshire so this would be
transferring transferring the emission
reduction responsibility from vehicle
essentially thank you any questions from
the
committee well representative sers so
you're concerned with uh thank you Mr
chair so you're concerned with the
emissions part right correct okay and is
it a is it a u a lot of work
to get the approvals or changes that you
saying has to be made it is we would
have to revise our our the re the
statute would be revision revised um
following that Dees would have to revise
our administrative rules and then we
would need to submit both the revised
Statute and our revised rules to the
Environmental Protection Agency for
their approval so that we were not in
violation of federal Clean Air Act
requirements and again that process
takes anywhere from 16 to 24
months follow up yeah yeah thank you so
I mean part of this that I'm reading
here it's like the the vehicle already
has a sticker and they're just saying
allow the stick what I was reading is
allow the sticker to run out to one year
so it doesn't seem like it would be in
violation there was a part of this where
is it okay um at the on the page
six uh Rond three it says no rule should
require onboard diagnostic system
inspection on vehicles over 15 model
years old and we currently inspect
Vehicles 20 model years old and
newer so we would have to and that's
both in our state statute and in our
rules so both would have to be revised
approval representative Jones is that
hand up yes thank you Mr chairman
um the last bill that you spoke to you
talked about the risk of uh losing
Federal funding is is that risk also
with this Bill yes it is thank
you any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you thank
you chair would now like to recognize
representative kushman the uh Prime
sponsor
sorry representative for me jumping the
gun at 11 I
apologize well I was late so who can
blame you I apologize for that um and uh
I'm sorry that I wasn't here in time to
introduce the bill but I I thank you for
um for the representative for
introducing it for me can you uh for the
record just yep for the record my name
is Leah kushman I represent the town of
we um I I brought this bill because I've
come to understand
politics is the art of the possible and
in a house that is nearly split down the
middle um in an issue that clearly a
full repeal of inspections or um you
know sweeping changes on the vehicle
inspections are not supported by the
House of
Representatives um and likely not the
Senate either so but people are having
hardship because of the inspections and
I know that you've all heard many times
the arguments for why why we should have
them why we shouldn't and I won't take
your time up there because I'm sure
you've heard it over and over again um
but people are really struggling um so
my husband is a mechanic I am a lay
person I only know
automotives because of what I have to
pay for and what my husband has to fix
and how long it takes and the fact that
I've gotten tickets for not having my
car inspected because he either wasn't
able to get the thing fixed in time or
we were saving up the money to replace a
part um you know and and it's just I'm
not the only one but I'm here for those
people who are really struggling this
economy is not great um so we just went
through the administrative rules my
husband and I um and kind of looked at
what things are not priority for
safety but also can cause some red ape
that ends up causing hardship for the
people um so go so we we literally just
went line by line and talked about you
know the different things and why is
this in place is it necessary for safety
maybe not in my husband's opinion um
he's working so he couldn't be here to
to help me um but it's technical most
most of it is pretty
straightforward you know for um it would
help if an inspection sticker could stay
with the vehicle from transfer of
ownership um I heard that there were
some challenges with that um you know
whatever can be preserved in this
bill that's possible to be preserved and
passed is better than what we have now
so if there's amendments that need to be
made um that's okay if if we see places
where we can open it up a little more
that's great um if you see things that
are just not workable that's
understandable I just want things to be
a little easier for the people and I
also put in um something in there to
make it easier for the inspection
stations also because they I spoke with
some mechanics my husband doesn't have a
shop by the way um he had one in
Massachusetts he's no longer a
practicing mechanic he has a new career
but that's what he did so he has all
that knowledge uh but so making it so
that the length of time that that an
inspection takes is not a trigger for
some kind of audit or uh penalty uh
that's
in you already talked about the
ownership transfer at the first part of
the
bill um the inspections station
one is at the be is on uh page four line
16 so it looks like a lot of text but
it's really just because we're adding
something at the end of that long
section of statue
um only the things at the very end of
the bill that are not in bold which I'll
go to are are not um bolded for you to
see where the new language is so
everything that's bolded is new
everything that's struck out is is a
change um up to page four that's where
that that other one with the um for the
stations is to give them a little help
um section three of the bill it starts
on line 24 page
for
um I got rejected for an inspection
personally because my wheel well had a
little bit of rust on the edge of
it and I was told that it's a hazard for
someone walking by and that that's why
so we talked about it and said if it
doesn't protrude more than a half an
inch maybe that you know it should be
okay to go people shouldn't be touching
your car really anyway
um so that was our thinking there that
might might end up making it
um that might end up making it so that
that surface rust you know that isn't
structural that people don't have to go
and spend thousands of dollars to get
that
fixed um then the light issue
so section
four on the back of page five you'll see
um it eliminates rust
as a factor on the light for for failing
it as long as rust or any other
imperfections exist on it but they don't
inhibit the ability of the light to do
its job and project um
effectively in my opinion should not
result in a failure um so I I added
there that um linear cracks in a head
lamp or reflecting surface shall not
cause inspection failure this is
actually about reflectors but it it car
cares over to the lights too in the next
section um you'll see number five no
directional
um no directional signal shall cause
inspection failure unless it doesn't
function properly is not properly
directed is obscured or has a minimum
light output and projection lower than
the vehicle's original equipment again
this this is to um address an
administrative rule that spoke to this
issue and I can get you each rule that
goes with each change I'll send an email
to the committee if you want that
reference that cross
reference um then you see
reflectors window function so these new
sections from line 30 on page five and
down um they're not bolded but that's
new um and the reason for these I can
explain each one we'll just go through
window function uh if someone's window
doesn't go up or down I don't think that
should result in them having to fail an
inspection um I don't think it really
has much to do with safety if you crash
into water you're going to break your
window if you're trying to get out of
your car you're going to use your door
or break your window if your door's not
working um and and if your door doesn't
work it just seems that it's overly
burdensome and that the
the um you know the the safety benefit
that we're going to get from it is
minimal um same with the exhaust pipe
inspection so my muffler fell off of my
car um going down my driveway and when
it came off it got punched a hole right
in it my husband got it and put it back
on but he had to weld the hole and I
think that's technically a patch and I
don't know like how many time like how
many people you know who have said oh I
have a hole in my muffler I have to get
it fixed you know and you hear that
sound you know that you've got a hole in
your
muffler what do we have to replace our
Muffler every time we get a hole based
on this rule that's kind of what it says
and buying a new muffler versus having
the tech just weld a patch or you know
close a hole seems common
sense
um and then just the restrictions on
rule making because a lot of these
things were in the rules and not in the
statute so that's why they addressed
that so that's on the last page um just
again with so door handles latches and
locks and hinges if any of them
um are broken I believe is what it says
in the administrative
rules uh that it would fail even
if uh the door
functions so say someone has you know
just like um a broken handle but they
can still open the door but maybe they
had to put you know tape over it these
are common things in lowincome sectors
of society especially with used cars
this Committee just gave a break to
people who can afford brand new
cars um to avoid inspections for the
first year um and and it's really people
who are struggling financially who are
mostly impacted by this law um by these
requirements then yes the last uh the
well I'll get to that one after but the
number two Roman two no rule shall
require wooden bumpers to be made of
hardwood that seems really arbitrary you
can have a bumper support made of metal
which is usually what it comes stock or
you can have a piece of wood with a
quarter inch piece of Steel in front of
it um but it says in the statute that
that wood has to be hardwood and I I
looked and I couldn't find any research
to say that hardwood is more resistive
or safe in a
crash than softwood so um I don't know
if the department has comments on that
but it seemed arbitrary to
me um and then number three no rues
should require onboard diagnostic system
inspection in vehicles over 15 model
years old we know that the OBD is not a
safety thing so that's why it's here of
course um I understand that there's no
will to eliminate it totally uh but a
lot of a lot of folks who are in
financial hardship have those vehicles
that are older than 15 years old and the
OBD is the most common reason that
people can't get their vehicle fixed and
have to get a new car um that I've I
I've experienced that's an
anecdote um you know you have a code and
no one can figure out where the code is
coming from but it's just you know it's
just something in the exhaust system
it's you know it doesn't it doesn't
affect how your car is running it
doesn't affect the vehicle safety but
it's this you know um rabbit hole that
the mechanic has to go down to diagnose
and it can end up costing hundreds and
hundreds of
dollars uh and then again that no rule
shall require inspection failure for a
functional headlamp lens or reflector
having linear cracks as long as it
functions if it's cracked in just a
linear meaning a line then it should be
okay and that's all and I I'll take any
questions thank you thank you
representative any questions from the
committee I have a question
chair um yeah Mr chairman can you just
tell tell me who you have cards for at
this time so I can direct my question to
the right person we have card we have
cards from um Dan Bennett from the New
Hampshire auto deals Association and
Lieutenant James Larry from the state
police and Jeremy
Olen representative
Sykes thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question I
just I just was curious I wanted to make
sure that this was not an unintended
consequence of your changes on page two
three um you take away an exceptions for
certain types of motorized vehicles you
take away ohrv snowmobiles mopeds and
rotable aircraft from being required to
have an inspection sticker I'm worried
that taking that out means that they
would I don't know if there's some other
RSA that would require them would also
exempt them but I don't want to suddenly
require those vehicles to have an
inspection sticker if they do not
currently if they're not currently
required to do so do you you have a
thought about that thank you for the
question uh from what I'm reading they
they need to have a an inspection
dealer yeah they have to have an
inspection sticker anyway it says they
shall be inspected not later than 10
days after the registration or transfer
of ownership so that's
just oh I'm sorry um that's line two
it's halfway through after the comma I'm
yeah after the comma shall be so all of
those that are listed not
withstanding notwithstanding those other
vehicles transferred to a licensed
dealer the ohrv snowmobiles mopeds
rotable aircraft and vehicles other than
Vehicles transferred to a licensed
dealer oh they kind of said that
twice anyway they shall not be inspected
later than 10 days after the
registration or transfer of ownership of
said vehicle but if you see some
problems in the language there that need
to be worked out I mean I would have no
objections if there's some unintended I
I'm not seeking to change what is
required to be inspected and what's not
okay thank you for
that representative
sellers thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm glad you brought
this up because I really believe the the
poor people are getting hammered I mean
really really bad and anything that we
can change the rules and make things
more clear is is
awesome and is for
yourself I guess how often has your
husband are you seeing how many people
that come in I mean they're super
struggling and just don't have the money
to repair this
stuff thank you for the question
um as far as super struggling I mean a
lot of the cars in Manchester if you
look around are not inspected or have um
old inspection stickers on them so I
know that in the cities it's much more
prevalent and I think it's not as
enforced there because of that um but
out in the rural areas it's enforced
pretty heavily
um I mean anecdotally I talking to
people everyone I've talked to has said
that this is a burdensome thing it's
it's more burdensome and it's more
difficult and there's more requirements
to pass an inspection in New Hampshire
than
Massachusetts um and then I can speak to
we're not we're average income household
70 $80,000 a year between my husband and
I and um you know we we've never had new
cars uh and people would say well if
you're tired of paying for all the
repairs go buy a new car I mean it's not
really fair you know to say to somebody
go put yourself into debt for 25 years
or or eight years or 12 years or however
long when you can barely afford just the
current repairs that go month to month
that you have to do so I I just think
that it it is affecting a lot of people
I don't have a number on it but uh
overwhelmingly pretty much everybody
that I have spoken to besides um people
here in in the house who um are either
State Police or or um Dees has supported
some kind of Reform on this because it's
too
burdensome any other questions from the
committee not seeing any thank you
you chair like to recognize Dan Bennett
from the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association uh who opposes the bill
minutes uh thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee um I'll be as brief as
possible Dan Bennett New Hampshire auto
dealers were a trade Association for the
motor vehicle industry in New Hampshire
um we're here opposed to HB 1637 as I
indicated on our card um as you've heard
us say before the annual inspection
program works in New Hampshire um and
it's right for New Hampshire as it is
for all of our New England states and
neighbors um you know we do run an
autocap program which is an automotive
uh consumer action panel that receives
complaints uh and we receive virtually
no complaints um on the inspection
process ESP especially in this bill as
it's related to time uh time for an
inspection uh I have sat through
thousands of inspections including
attending class from both state state
police and the community college system
in New Hampshire which teaches classes
on Automotive inspection um and there is
absolutely no reference to minimum or
maximum time um for inspections
conducted just um having sat through
them um the marriage of the inspection
and the registration system works really
well in New Hampshire um it works for
the town clerks it works for the
stations um and so um to to move off
that Mark um which is I think pretty
universally accepted um seems
unnecessary um it also wipes out when
there is a problem with that type of
marriage of those two things we have a
16-month inspection option we used to
call it the snowbird option right if you
were in Florida in January and that's
when your inspection was due you could
get it done four months early this bill
actually wipes out the 16mon inspection
so we take away that um that U component
of that that we've we've honored for the
folks who need that accommodation uh to
make things a little bit easier but I
think it's uh in one of the line line 10
it wipes it out
um a couple the other things that I um
that I wanted to mention bouncing around
a little bit from some of the things um
that I've heard um I mean there's a
safety requirement in there to have
doors that securely close in a vehicle
uh that seems like a common sense safety
requirement for us to have functioning
um functioning doors um that securely uh
stay closed
um the bill modifies the inspections and
Emissions program um to vehicles that
are no more than than 15 years old um
you heard from the Department of
Environmental Services and we mentioned
this last time around you have no idea
whether the EPA will actually even
approve this exemption this is a shoot
first aim second approach that doesn't
do the homework on the front end to know
if we're going to be even afforded that
exemption which has severe
implications if you do in fact go for
that exemption the EPA is is surely
going to want to make sure that we have
those emission reductions so they're
going to get their pound of Flesh and
you got to figure out who it's going to
fall on because if we're going to give
older dirtier cars a free pass is it
going to be the truckers the
manufacturers the power plants uh
somebody's going to have to make up
those emissions reductions and actually
contrary to what we heard on the bill
that you all had a few weeks ago you
said the reason that we were okay with
the emissions reductions was because
newer cars are cleaner and they don't
pollute well now on the back side of it
a couple weeks later we're giving a pass
to what you would say would be the older
dirtier cars so those two those two um
kind of concepts are at odds um there's
also the component that I'll mention um
about sales Cycles you know um
throughout the year there's different
sales cycles for vehicles uh President
Day right everybody has heard of that
one or the end of the year type sale um
currently the way the inspection program
works is it's pretty even Keel over 12
months what this will do to shops that
do conduct inspections is create a
rather erratic flow during times of high
sales low sales Seasons um and and in
the inspection stations um workload will
will fluctuate pretty severely um and
then um I heard the word hardship
mentioned a lot um I think if it um
maybe we can get some information from
DMV the OBD2 emissions testing program
as this committee knows because you
helped write the law has a hardship
waiver exemption for people who cannot
afford to have emissions repairs done or
if there's some glitch in the system
that the manufacturer just cannot work
around the emissions testing component
um those two things a hardship wave
can and are administered by and and
given to Citizens by the DMV um they may
have some de on that um and then just
couple notes that I jotted as we go um I
also heard that Massachusetts versus New
Hampshire um and that new inspections
are much more difficult in New Hampshire
um I'm very familiar with with both
systems um and that's just not the case
Massachusetts has a live videos Feed
inside every inspection station not
building Bay service Bay with a live
feed that State Police monitors the
inspections being conducted and they can
halt it on the spot it is a very very
burdensome um intrusive approach to um
to conducting safety and Emissions
Inspection so um R2 um it's state set
you know our our program in New
Hampshire is free market based you don't
like the cost of it vote with your
wallet and go find another station that
offers a cheaper different type uh of
inspection so um as mentioned I just get
back to um it's our opinion that the
inspection program and system in New
Hampshire um isn't broken um and um and
for that those reasons um we're opposed
to
1637 um and um I I'll attempt to answer
any questions if I can thank you so much
any questions from the committee
representative Coker thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr re so um you
mentioned you know shoot first aim
second and the prime sponsor she said
that she's open to input and friendly
amendments is there anything in this
bill that you look at and you go we can
do this because I know you say you don't
get a lot of complaints but like I get a
ton of complaints from all aspects from
the new cars to the the old cars I mean
people are pissed at this program so
like I would love any kind of input you
have on any of these sections that we
might be able even one little thing you
know it's it's good for both of us it's
good for the industry and it's good for
for the
people uh well so to answer the question
in reference to the emissions component
um you know the the the shoot first a
second I mean Dees the folks who write
the grants for approval just told you it
takes 16 to 24 months to even get a
decision to know if we would even be
allowed to modify that so so I would
think we might want to do our homework
first that's one I guess suggestion and
then at times um I would say our
industry has um supported um changes to
the programs when there are a problem in
the inspection program um we attack it
with a scalpel not a hatchet and
fine-tune those things like we did with
uh uh a session or two ago we did it um
for uh window tin we also did it for
surface rust we worked with Deputy
speaker Smith on a bill that would uh
tweak around the edes um and I believe
chairman Walsh as well to tackle um
surface rust issues that were not safety
related surface issues that could
potentially cause reasons for failure so
we wiped that component out so yeah
there are times when we do when we do
work to um uh you know on on on issues
to to improve the program to lessen some
of the burden uh what be my response
follow follow up um so so just to be
clear you don't see anything I mean like
the emission stuff I mean it sounds like
she's willing to really work with you
you don't see anything in this bill that
might be worth putting
through um well I guess you know if we
were to take the time and do some
homework then maybe we could chat about
stuff you know I don't profess to be an
expert on the crashworthiness of
hardwood versus softw you know maybe
it's something that we could sit down
and explore it's something that I'm not
familiar with but you know just um the
the bill is it as a whole the way that
it's written right now because we're not
talking about pieces we're talking about
the bill as a whole right now on paper
as it stands we're opposed to it all
right thank you any other questions from
the committee representative
sers thank you Mr chair so how could we
amend this bill to make it easier for
the people that are poor because I'm
with representative ER it's I'm getting
hammered left and right and I'm getting
emails saying our inspection stickers
are crazy and they're unjust and they're
just not working and the people are just
absolutely mad so how can we fix this
and go forward to help those people
especially the especially the people
that for I'm thinking kids that are
going through college you know they're
just trying to get through college with
the car they got and it's it it we all
know it's not the best cow they're just
trying to get college and those that are
just with family with two or three kids
they're they're just dying out there how
can you we need some suggestions from
you that's what I'm asking you how can
you help us
out uh yeah I guess um
so couple quick responses um I would
hope that when you do get those
constituent calls you um refer them to
either our autocap program or the
Attorney General's office or to State
Police because those are the ones that
handle and and help resolve those issues
um and then you know as
um I guess as as far as changes um if
what this committee wants to do is is
take a hard look um at some of those
items we'd be welcome to have those
discussions um like we did on the last
bill I would truly bring in uh the
experts the folks that do it every
single day that are in the trenches the
the technicians that that see the type
of vehicles that roll in um and then
lastly uh
um you
know college kid families Rich poor we
should all be safe whether you're
driving or whether it's the uh 3,000 lb
missile that's going 80 M an hour in the
opposite lane coming towards me on a
believe representative say clear thank
you m Mr chair um and thank you you
mentioned the hardship application yes
sir so if if person applies for the
hardship do you do can you tell me the
length of time that takes to get through
where it's either granted or denied and
if that stops the inspection right there
how that works yeah uh so R St Clair I
wish that I had could answer that for
you we don't administer the program it's
written in the rules and it's
administered by the DMV and uh I believe
they're signed off personally by the DMV
director um so I would say we can
certainly ask DMV to give us some
hardship info but they're the ones that
are holder of
thata I thought you might know that so
much thank you Mr chair again yeah you
you mentioned that 3,000 pound missile
and I I don't disagree with you but some
things aren't uh like a rust hole in the
fender is not going to be a 3,000 pound
missile I'm just really asking you how
can we amend this bill right here give
us some ideas what we can do to make it
easier for the people out there that's
all I'm asking is there anything you can
supply and help the representatives with
to help us fix this at least with
something give us something is there
anything you can help us
with as I mentioned we're always o open
to to doing the homework and having this
discussion utilizing um you know like I
said the experts in the field who do it
every single day that see stuff in all
shapes and sizes um but on paper as this
one stands right now I don't have
anything to offer for you without um
know any other questions from the
committee we still have like three other
speakers that want to talk about this
not seeing any thank you thank you Mr
chairman chair I like to recognize
Jeremy Olsen um who supports the bill
who's representing himself asking for
three
minutes
uh good morning um members of the
committee and thank you for allowing me
to testify today so the first thing I
would like to say is I am 100% in
support of this bill as it's written and
would like to see it passed but one
thing I would like to point out is that
as um the sponsor originally said a lot
of the stuff it's responses to problems
that we have right now sections 3
through 9 it's all the different
problems that people have found with
mechanics finding problems that
shouldn't be considered safety problems
and what I'd like to offer is another
idea sounds like people are open to the
idea of amending it representative
salers for example and um what I'd like
to
offer is that the state consider adding
something to the to the rules that allow
like an actual due process system right
now when people have these problems with
mechanics they don't know where to T it
you bring it to one mechanic they decide
that there's a problem with your car and
it's something trivial it's non-safety
like linear cracks in your headlights or
surface rust or something once they plug
the car into the computer there you try
to take it to another mechanic most
mechanics do not want to touch the car
because they don't want to be accused of
doing like the what they call the lick
it and stick it thing where they're just
taking the car and running it through
because it's already in the system
there's all sorts of other problems with
um so there's no way to get a second
opinion right now I'm I followed car
inspection stuff for years I have never
heard of the program that the Dealers
Association runs for complain compl
process so I would say that very very
few other people out there probably
heard of that program either so what
would make sense is that like many other
programs in the DMV if you have your
driver's license suspended there's a
quasi judicial process that goes on
within the DMV to appeal a driver's
license suspension and obviously you can
eventually go to court on that I would
propose that the committee create an
amendment to this bill that allows for a
similar due process if you have a
problem with the inspection station
number one you could get a second an
opinion from another station without any
kind of problems there and number two
that there's some kind of hearing
process that's expeditious in the DMV
where you can have them review what the
mechanic said they can have experts say
okay that mechanic was overreaching we
can overrule that or something like that
um another idea that I came up that I
came up with just listening to the
representative for the Dealers
Association talk about when you go to
mechanic like when you have to have work
done on your car there have the state
law I don't know what law it is but it
requires them to post a notice right
there that descri Des cribes like you
know your rights and and appeal rights
like if they give you a quote and they
go over the quote they're not allowed to
go over 10% and so on maybe some of
these appeal processes that already do
exist like this private one that's run
and the hardship for the OBD maybe
inspection station should be required to
post a notice right there on the desk
that says you have these appeal rights
if you disagree with what you get what
you get from this particular mechanic
that would be my main recommendations I
like the bill the way it's written but
if we're going to be amending it sending
it to a subcommittee or something I'd be
more than happy to help participate in
coming up with some ideas for like an
appeals process a mandatory notice
process something to make it easier for
people to actually know that there's a
way of getting their car inspected if
they can't get it to their first
mechanic and they're worried about
thousands of dollars of repairs because
the lights on um that's all I have to
say today and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
the
committee not seeing any thank
you chair I like to recognize Steve
zek uh who supports the bill asking for
three
minutes hi I'm Steve manik I'm live in
Manchester I support the bill uh as even
as written I think it's a step in the
right direction but uh I don't think
it's going to solve a lot of problems um
I think the legislature has tried to fix
the uh inspection system a few times
over the years for example a couple
years ago they had a bill is opposed to
eliminate what I would consider cosmetic
rust from causing failures and yet years
later people are still getting hassled
over what I would consider cosmetic rust
and fenders and stuff like that that
really don't impact safety so I'd rather
see the whole program just eliminated
but I know that's never going to happen
so you could you could dream um the
things I do like about the bill is I
really like the uh elimination of of the
uh birthday annual birthday present of
having to go get an inspection sticker
um I'm my birthday is in the fall I'd
much rather go and do everything for the
year for my truck in the springtime
because you know after the winter I you
know I'll spend a whole weekend working
on it washing it and fixing whatever
needs to be repaired over the winter and
that sort of thing I'd rather go and get
my inspection sticker done then and be
not have to think about it for the rest
of the year um so
uh and uh also uh I grew up in
Massachusetts um I'm not sure how it is
now it's I know it is pretty bad where
they have setup cameras and all that
sort of thing um but when I when I was
when I lived in Massachusetts on
Saturdays a lot of mechanic shops just
had walk-in inspections where there's
just a line of cars and you drive up you
wait in line you pull into the bay
and it's like a NASCAR pit stop uh where
a couple guys come out with you know
floor jacks Jack the car up check it
real quick turn on your headlights turn
on your left turn signal right turn
signal honk the horn and uh you were out
of there in less than 15 minutes uh I've
gotten inspection stickers literally
without getting out of the truck and
it's not like I went to some sketchy
place or knew a guy I just went to the
place on you know the main drag uh that
does it on weekends so I when I moved to
New Hampshire many many years ago and I
go get my inspection sticker I was just
blown away at what a pain in the ass it
was
so um let's see what else I put down
here uh and I am uh I the only thing
with Leah's bill is I think she should
replace the words linear crack with
hairline crack because linear just means
a straight line so um but I've seen
people fail for literally hairline
cracks that you could barely see and you
couldn't even feel with your fingernail
um and uh some of these headlights and
tail lights and stuff uh are really
really expensive right now um I had my
grandfather broke a tail light on his
car um putting something in the back of
it and it was a $300 just for the part
and that was with my employee discount
um and uh and I know on my truck one of
the head like plastic housings is $500
each so uh if I have a tiny little
hairline crack uh I'm probably not going
to replace it until like it actually
becomes a problem so if I'm getting
jammed up on an inspection sticker for a
tiny hairline crack and have to spend
$500 just for the plastic housing I'm
going to be very very
pissed um let's
see uh and I think that one of the
things is 20% of people fail inspection
every year and I think if 20% of the
vehicles on the road were really
actually unsafe we would be having
accidents all over the place but that's
not the case
um and it in New Hampshire is only one
of a few states that has an inspection
program uh and you know there's not
really any noticeable difference and
even if you look at accident statistics
and what percentage of accident are
caused by uh a mechanical failure
um you don't even necessarily know if
those mechanical failures would have
been detected by an inspection uh
because you could have a brand new tire
have a blowout and cause an
accident um let's
see
um and one thing I'd really like to see
is um if mechanics were able to have a
little bit of leniency when they do an
inspection and rather than have it be
absolute pass or absolute fail if they
could just be like hey you should
probably fix this but you can still have
your sticker there's no leniency in
letting them you know just give you a
caution on hey you should probably keep
an eye on this or you might want to
replace this in a couple months or
anything like that it's it's pass or
fail so if you have the tiniest little
bit of play in a bushing or something
they're going to fail it and you could
probably go for months and months and
months and you know either save up money
for the repair
or you know just wait until Springtime
or whatever it may be to to to take care
of it but it's always um you got to fix
it right
now um and uh one thing that uh and one
thing about uh they mentioned like this
is a free market program I completely
disagree and one of the things that I
would Point as evidence that it's
unnecessary and is not a free market is
even in states that don't have an
inspection sticker program but have
mandatory Insurance none of the
insurance companies ever require people
to go and get an annual inspection on
their car so if it was truly a free
market and uh the uh it was actually an
issue that needed to be addressed the
actuaries at these insurance companies
would totally require people go and get
their vehicles inspected every year but
they don't um and one thing that I think
would probably be an improvement to the
system uh that might actually kind of
make it a little bit more difficult for
some people but I would really improve
safety is uh I don't think that um
dealers should be allowed to sticker
their own cars that they're selling if
they're selling a used car um I've gone
and with friends to go look at a car
they were thinking about buying and look
it over and um for example one time I uh
I plugged my scan tool in and read the
codes and I was getting all these um
codes for the ABS system the the lock
brakes and um I wasn't seeing a light up
on the
dashboard and when I took a really close
look at the dashboard I noticed that
somebody painted over the um the uh OBD
light on the
dashboard and uh and you know I think if
you're sell if you're the one selling
the car you're going to be a little bit
more lenient than you know the
inspection station is going to be
looking at the car um you know in a
couple months when here's your birthday
birthday again and uh the other thing is
there's no consistency between
inspection stations and or even the same
even two mechanics at the same
inspection station um because it seems
like whenever anyone complains about the
inspection sticker process online
everybody comments well you went to the
wrong place you should have gone to you
know Bob's Auto Repair instead of Jim's
auto repair uh if if the system was
consistent it wouldn't matter and that's
all I have to say any questions thank
you any questions for the committee not
seeing any thank you all right thank you
chair i' like to call Lieutenant James o
from the New Hampshire State Police who
opposes the bill he's asking for 10
minutes if he can make it a little bit
it good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee I will make it less than
10 minutes depending upon your
questions um I have with me AI
supervisor Ken chaput he oversees our
inspection program so he oversees the
people that um conduct the audits of
inspection stations I brought him along
in case you had any specific questions
that I wasn't able to answer I'm not
going to go through everything uh line
by line uh most of the stuff that the
Auto Dealers Association said we're in
agreement with there are a couple of
things that I would like to kind of
highlight I do applaud the
representative for bringing this type of
a bill forward in the sense that I think
that from what I'm hearing from
representative sers and representative
Koker you know we are in a scenario
where we want more clarification uh I
think collectively even industry
included on what is safety related and
you know what is not safety related and
how can we make improvements to the
program uh the bill that she brought
forth attempts to do that obviously it's
just that there are some things in there
that um I think that we need to look at
a little more closely to just make sure
that we're making the appropriate
changes so for example like like Dan
spoke about with the wooden bumper I'm
not sure what the wood makes that's the
way the rues been maybe it's arbitration
or maybe there was a purpose for it but
it would be nice to kind of look through
that first to make sure that that's a
proper change you know as it relates to
the headlight rule um when we start
making changes to rules and laws as it
relates to the mechanics they need a way
in which they can conduct or perform the
test that's equal across the board we're
hearing that it's discretionary in
different locations and how how are the
they are performing it we don't perform
currently a uh test on light intensity
so to determine whether or not rust or
crack or water or condensation you know
affect the proper application of the
light would be difficult because we
don't perform that test currently now if
we were to explore language you know to
to address that that's uh something that
we could look at so as it relates to
each one of those individual changes
um for for those types of reasons the
testing reasons mainly uh how a mechanic
can perform a proper test to determine
whether or not a repair to uh an exhaust
is proper we again that opens it up for
interpretation and that's what we're
trying to get away from so I guess and
long and short of it we would be looking
to work on additional language to try to
to put uh some more clarification
forward in that area as it relates to
notifications on the vehicle inspection
report we made changes to that over the
past year um currently there are
notifications that do allow a customer
to know that they can request an OBD
waiver the OBD waiver process
representative St Clair is a two-e
process uh it takes two weeks to turn
around that request and that waiver is
good for one year that gives the
applicant a year to fix the OBD issue or
emissions issue that they have with
their
car um the idea
of
um the a complaint process again there
there's that phone number that's in
place currently on those virs and those
and that's uh those are investigations
that that we would uh follow up on not
knowing specific specifically what the
constituents are um having issues with
for their specific Vehicles it's tough
to say like what areas we can make
improvements there but I would say uh
the two last very quick topics one
changing the when the inspection is due
as much as I can appreciate the reason
for it I think it becomes challenging
for mechanics and vehicle owners to
remember when their inspection uh is due
to expire at that point when you have
multiple vehicles that expired at
different times um it it could be
difficult for a consumer to remember
when their inspection is due and it does
take away that 16mon um ability for
somebody to have their vehicle inspected
four months prior to uh the expiration
the last part that I just want to speak
to is the amount of time it takes to
conduct an inspection so we've heard for
a number of years the issues uh
involving inspection stations and that
you know uh State Police and Company do
uh follow up on complaints uh that are
that are forwarded to us and one of the
things that is looked at is the amount
of time it takes to perform uh an
inspection now the this the language in
here says we shall not require an
inspection station to perform
inspections within any minimum or
maximum amount of time well currently we
do not we don't do that we don't require
a minimum or maximum time limit on an
inspection um reading further no penalty
or audit should result based on the
amount of time spent on inspections
whether individually or on average there
is no penalty that currently takes place
dependent upon time however that being
said when one of our AIS goes to perform
an audit one of the things that they do
look at is what's called a trigger
analysis report that report basically
lays out all inspections that are
conducted by an inspection station two
things they look at one are they
plugging in the vehicle that they're
supposed to be plugging in so are they
bypassing tamper tampering emissions two
how long are they taking in between
inspections because if you see that
there's a station that's performing
inspections every five minutes and and
they have one inspector and they've
completed 50 inspections in an 8 hour
period Then it tends to reason that
there's something that's not going on uh
that's proper there and that and that
would be part of an audit so I guess you
know our discussion currently with these
station owners there is no repercussions
for any time constraints but we do have
a discussion uh during the audit to
determine what are they doing that is
inspections thank you any questions from
the committee representative
Veer thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um I would like to
reiterate what other reps have said that
this is one of the areas where I get the
most complaints um and a lot of it has
to do with the ambiguity between the
rules and the laws like I had a a
constituent who called me and was pretty
upset he he has rust but he was reading
the law and said uh it's not protruding
it's not loose it's not causing a hazard
why did I fail my inspection I said well
called Troop G and see what they say and
he was told to go to a different
inspection station and if he passed then
he could b a plate he said I don't want
to have to pay a second inspection fee
so what does the the appeals process
look like and do you have to get do you
have to actually pass someplace else
before you're accepted as a PL thank you
for your question so uh two components
of that I do agree with you that rust uh
is an area in which we could that you
know included in this law the language
here I actually think is is good it
starts to kind of narrow down uh the
issue with rust and uh what can be
what's what is a failure So currently
the way the process works is if they do
contact us um there are times in which
we will send out either an AI or a
trooper to look at the vehicle to see
whether or not it should or should not
pass inspection the difficulty becomes
that we are not in the business of
conduct conducting motor vehicle
inspections um so if they do bring it to
another location and that uh person does
pass the test and it does give us the
ability to either address the if it if
they have violated a rule it does g give
us the ability to go back and discuss
that issue with that original Mechanic
now that being said one of the gentlemen
that spoke earlier had I thought a
pretty good idea on the fact of having
an appeals process because that does
happen you could bring it to one
location and that person failures you
and if you do bring it to a second
location that person passes you what is
the recourse for a consumer um you know
some people know that they can call us
and and there is a recourse but other
than that you may not be aware of it and
I think an administrative proceeding
like like that might be something that's
useful or at least worth talking about
thank you for your
question representative St Clair do you
have a question I do thank you and thank
you yes sir um you said there was no
time
limit on on each side yes sir but five
minutes raises a question in your mind
so I get that so where is the cut off
where it doesn't raise a question there
must be something in your mind that says
five minutes 10 minutes 15 thank you for
your question so we don't necessarily
look at one single uh inspection what
we're looking at is a pattern of
inspection so when we see multiple
vehicles that are inspected over a
period of time that let's say five 3 to
five minutes that these inspections are
passing through that is an area in which
we would look at a little bit further
you know we're also comparing what year
vehicles are we looking at are they 2005
are they 15 20 years old and you know
there's one shop that's passing 25 cars
in an 8 hour period then uh it stands
the reason that there's concerned
whether or not their vehicles are being
properly inspected now if I were to see
one car that was inspected in 5 minutes
that's not even something we would
really look at it's more again it's a
pattern of behavior that we're looking
to
identify thank you representative foot
thank you Mr chair uh thank you
lieutenant sir for my own edification so
the certification to inspect is that per
the station or is that each employee so
could that be the discrepancies amongst
these auto shops so the certification
the the the station itself is licensed
and then the mechanic is licensed it has
own certification if that I don't know
if I'm answering your question properly
but essentially not everybody at the
location you could have an owner of the
business who was not certified and a
mechanic who is okay thank you yes sir
questions thank you Mr chair um quick
question you mentioned the trigger
analysis yes sir um how often is that
done and is it done electronically
through central office because
everything's online versus how often our
physical uh inspections done at
inspection stations thank you for your
question so the trigger analysis is
generated during an audit so every uh
every two years we try to get into audit
every station of course there's seven
people that do it
and 1,700 stations so we do the best we
can with that um so every two years
we're auditing stations and uh at that
time is when that trigger analysis
report is pulled and that is an
electronic report that's uh generated
through Gordon Darby our our uh our
vendor that does our uh online
stickering thank you thank you
chair thank you Mr chair so some of the
complaints I've actually had is is
Fender rust and also uh believe it or
not I don't know how it's possible but
having rust on the
brakes that cause failure and also I
mean uh a wheel bearing you know uh how
do you how do you determine the wheel
bearing is is actually bad at that point
or is it you know what margin is there
on stuff like that thank you for your
question as far as the wheel bearing is
concerned there's a manufacturer
specification for each vehicle and so
when the mechanic is doing the test they
will measure the amount of play that
using one of their tools and they will
determine they'll compare that that play
that that looseness if you will in that
component to whatever the manufacturer
specifications are so if it's beyond
that limit then it is required to be
replaced
one more followup thank you I'm sorry
this is this is some of the things that
the consumer doesn't know and so when
they go into the garage they they they
say yeah you got wheel bearing play but
it's never as said according to your
specs I mean how do how does the
consumer deal with stuff like that they
just said yeah your wheel bearing is
failing yeah well thank you for your
question I you know a lot of that is
contingent upon the the inspection
station they go to to some of them will
supply with those specifications and
some of them just don't um as a matter
of course so um it really would be
contingent upon who they're dealing with
and um you know and potentially asking
that question for the information but to
your point would the average consumer
know to ask that question or what
they're looking for probably
not any other
questions not seeing any thank you very
much at this point I have nobody else
who wants to testify I will close the
I'm going to open up the public hearing
on House Bill 1273 FN relative to the
protection of personal information and
driver's licenses chair recognizes the
prime sponsor representative ol good
afterno thank you Mr chair for the
record my name is Jordan oler Hillsboro
13 this bill was introduced because of
some personal experiences and some
uh complaints of uh residents within uh
the town of Hudson uh previously I had
experience with CVS which has been
successfully uh resolved wherein if you
went and got a prescription CVS would
scan your driver's license record the
information and then share that with the
National Police Department particularly
with uh um uh the purchase of narcotic
information CVS is sense because of
existing law under RSA 264 14 stopped
supposedly stopped that practice at
least they have for me when I pick up
stuff for my wife as a result of the
both either or both CVS retaining the
information and the natural police
retaining the information several things
took place firstly we're getting
advertisements regarding the type of uh
medication my wife is taking for chronic
illness secondly the National Police are
now aware of the medical condition of my
wife information to which they have no
legitimate
purpose more recently however I was able
to ship some packages down to family
members I went to FedEx over on Amber
Street in Nashville and they scanned the
driver's license and recorded all the
information on the driver's license and
they were told it was perfectly illegal
to do
that except I don't believe it
is this bill attempts to impose
penalties upon uh individuals or
businesses entities that record that
information uh if they uh lose it or if
it they get hacked or whatever the
driver's license information by
definition belongs to the driver and for
legitimate law enforcement
purposes but allowing businesses to
access the information that is on that
through whatever means whether it's just
this or that or a section of it or
something
else defeats the purpose of maintaining
privacy of your driver information which
was the impetus uh when uh represent
then representative Neil Kirk passed RSA
2614 tweaks have been made to the law to
allow for legitimate access and
legitimate access to some of that
information should be allowed for a
caseby casee specific purpose however
there's no reason in the world that uh
let's say Irving Gas should uh
demand you either scan your driver's
license at an Irving station or you send
them a photocopy of your driver's
license with all of the data that's out
contained on it to them in order to sign
up for Irving pay uh as an example or
should any other um uh company engaged
in that particular activity a quick
check at the uh the people opposed to
this bill indicate that they are engaged
in the financial trades and I do believe
uh the financial trades are already
excluded under existing law uh this
would be for other businesses to take
place the fact of the matter uh
colleagues is that uh our driver's
license information is not private and
yet we have a constitutional obligation
I think it's 2B part one 2B which says
that we have a right to privacy on the
information that the government contains
well either we do or we don't and if
we're just going to allow everyone to
have access to this information and do
it willy-nilly with no penalty for them
why do we have the bill why do we have
that law in the first place why are we
keeping some information private why not
just say it's all public now I do have
problems with some of RSA
2614 because of what happened over in
Milford and what happened in Lichfield
with property taxes regarding actually
motor vehicle taxes where there was uh
well some people went to jail for it uh
because of uh and that was discovered by
individuals who pulled records uh and
and took a look comparing the the the
charges that were made by their
neighbors but for legitimate purpose on
a case- by casee basis the same standard
that applies to the police and if you
remember recently in newspapers a police
officer was uh indicted by the Attorney
General's office for that uh that's
perfectly fine that's that's
understandable and that's reasonable but
on a broad basis of doing it to ship a
package by FedEx to get a prescription
from
CVS to order a uh an automatic bill pay
off off of your uh cell
phone to be held by some third party
someplace for per imp perpetuity where
you have no control over it
whatsoever seems to me to be a bit much
um I hope I did a a reasonable job in
putting
uh uh this the information in here some
of it is addition to existing uh law
some of it is not um I would also
indicate that uh most of our driver's
licenses are carrying a gold well it's
not a gold star it's a clear star
instead of a go gold Circle for real ID
and that only verifies to a to an
individual and it's also contained in
the scanning information that the uh
person has been
verified I don't know how many of you
are getting phone calls to the tune of
10 or 20 a day regarding your um
Medicare that it's now the Open
Enrollment program for Medicare it which
is a state funed program did you know
that I didn't know that Medicare was
state funded but you know there's a scam
running around uh for mature
information when you find that
information it should
probably be a penalty for the violation
of your private
information so i' be happy to answer any
questions although I do have caucus and
then a uh executive across the
hall thank you representative any
questions from the committee
representative sellers Mr chair I just
wonder who else is speaking on this I
have signed up uh Dan Bennett from NADA
infantine I do have one question sir for
full disclosure uh I was also infuriated
with uh the U grocery stores Irvings ra
AIDS all that collecting my personal
information by mandating that they scan
it I went to file a bill and they told
me I couldn't because yours was too
similar
um um so here we are the question I have
uh because what infuriated me was that I
was told well this is the solution you
don't have to give up your information
you just can't shop here or you don't
have to buy the products here which I
think is outrageous does your bill
address that does it prohibit a business
from denying service to you if you
merely want to show them your license as
opposed to them scanning it which I'm
fine with they need to be able to verify
I have no problem showing my ID to to
pick up my my wife uses narcotics I have
no problem showing that this is who I am
I don't even have any problem with them
writing that name down to show who
picked up that particular um um drug I
do have a problem with them scanning the
information off of it retaining that
information as for a business to denying
access which it seems to me that would
come under uh the facult that you're
open to the public and uh to deny person
because of you know race Creed color
whatever uh brings us back to the 40s
rather than the 20s yep fair enough
thank you uh representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question um my problem is the retain
the word you just used the retaining of
the information and
um and I'm I'm not sure what we do when
um the vendor says um we're not
retaining it um Andor it's company
policy so um I wondered if you would
comment on either of those two
things if they say they're not retaining
it and they do and then there's later a
breach you have a proof that they they
were U misleading the
public scanning it for an instantaneous
analysis still releases that information
and is being held someplace for a period
of time showing it on the other hand is
you still have access to it here see
this is who I am thank you very much
good day I'm I'm over 21 I can buy
alcohol I I'm over 21 I can buy
cigarettes alcohol yes cigarettes not so
much won't say anything about a small
store in Kingsboro uh
but the um retaining of it is the
serious situation and that should be
barred one way or
another yep follow up the company policy
answer um well the company policy we get
to tell the companies we get to tell the
towns and cities what the law is the
company policy needs to conform around
that a company policy could be that the
ball tires are perfect you just did
motor vehicle inspection company policy
doing could be uh all tires are
perfectly fine uh but state law says
tread representative sellers thank you
thank you Mr chair I was told by the DMV
the barcode on the back when it is
scanned reads every single piece of
information on the front that's that
they can actually see now I'm not sure
if the how do we how do we know that a
uh a merchant is retaining that
information without without doing
investigation that comes to the point of
scanning the driver's license in the
first place just bar the scanning
therefore you know that that information
is not being retained either
purposefully for marketing purposes or
incidentally because they didn't bother
to put in software to block it or
it okay seeing no other questions thank
you
representative um next up chair
recognize is representative will
infantine representing himself opposed
minutes good morning uh my name is Will
infantine I represent uh District in
Manchester and I'm the uh chairman of
the labor committee I don't come in
front of Transportation often so it's
nice to see you folks
it pains me to come and and speak
against my good friend's bill um I too
like he protect my privacy and I take it
seriously and thinking about testifying
today I had to give my ID to give blood
yes last week um I traveled this weekend
so I had to give my identification my ID
to go on an airplane rent a car and go
to a hotel so uh it's always interesting
to me you know who has my
information I'm speaking today purely
from a business standpoint I'm an
insurance agent I've owned an insurance
agency for 25 years and part of the
information I need to get someone
insurance for a
vehicle um is their driving record and
to get that insurance companies need
your driver's license numbers so I
routinely my company routinely takes
that information we keep it in our
files and then we present it to an
insurance
company so someone can you know get a
quote for their insurance so while I do
protect
my privacy and I like some of the things
the the presenter of the bill stated
there's some things I just can't live
with to be able to transact
business um I do possess information I
don't know how I possess it I I would
have to go through thousands of
different uh people's names and policies
on my computer to find out whose
information I have retained some people
will send us screenshots of their
driver's
licenses so um getting rid of that bill
requires me to get rid of that secondly
um if I any private business that shares
personal information of a driver's
license could be up a penalty of $10,000
I I'm guilty I do it I have no other
choice if you want an insurance quote
for your home and your your vehic icle I
have to share that information with an
insurance
company so try to think of all the
different businesses um that do things
for legitimate reasons to
help you know our our constituents here
in the state versus other ones which
without question may utilize information
to Market or sell you something or for
inappropriate
reasons so for that reason unfortunately
I do oppose the bill
um and for I guess I should probably let
you know that I do um I am the New
Hampshire representative to the national
board of directors of insurance agents
um so as I've said before I'm the
biggest Insurance geek in in the room um
so you know for those reasons I just
uh I we just wouldn't be able to live
with
this thank you very much thank you um I
do have a question I'll lead with you
say you're doing it now doing it now is
that in violation of the current law
too when someone when we well in your
your
industry am I currently violating New
Hampshire law by by retaining the
information if I am every insurance
agent in this in the state is so um I
don't believe I'm violating the current
law okay well what I my my I guess I
probably should have started at a
different direction would you be opposed
to because we do have some exceptions to
the law for certain businesses would you
be opposed to and what would would have
changed your opinion if there was a more
detailed uh exemption to the insurance
industry for legitimate purposes yes of
course thank you represent sers on the
same line I was thinking thank you Mr
chair I was thinking would you uh not be
opposed to because hipper allows sharing
information from doctor to doctor things
like that would that same type of
sharing would if we put an exception in
here work
yes it
would because we share repeatedly
especially if someone um insurance
companies as you all know sometimes your
policy increases from one year to the
other so your agent's responsibility is
to present it to all his cares to see if
he can do something different so I could
be doing this you know taking one
person's information a husband a wife
who live in a home and sharing their
information with 10 different insurance
companies every two
years
further questions from the
committee representa I saw
representative St Clair
um you understand of course the fear
that or the difference I guess is the
best word the difference between an
insurance company where you have a fixed
business and you're somebody you're
dealing with and going into a
convenience store or into a a bar where
they're scanning all this information
you do understand the difference in the
fear so what's the what do you think
amendment it's very
difficult I again as I said I don't like
sharing my information but we have so
many inconsistencies
here as I was speaking to the chairman
prior to the the bill there is is there
possibly something out there where the
department of uh Liquor Commission comes
down on a a place for not scanning or
not getting information I don't know
some of the inconsistencies we have it
has become it has
become um the Wild Wild West out there
grabbing your identification for almost
anything and unfortunately we've all
accepted it we just do it as a course of
business not knowing what information
we're giving out to someone we just
figured okay they looking at our date of
birth maybe and that's um going to prove
that we're old enough to buy cigarettes
or or alcoh H uh what about when we vote
uh Manchester has these new scanning
things where we ask if your ID and they
they to to verify who you are I mean
where where does it start where does it
end I don't know but you I agree
specifically that for anyone utilize
that
information um for marketing or sales or
to give out to other um entities that
have nothing to do with the purpose for
you receiving it should be
illegal
seeing no other questions thank you very
much thank you nice seeing you
all our chair recognizes Dan Bennett
from the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association opposed to the bill seeking
three
minutes good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh once again I
find myself the last lobbyist between
you and lunch so I'll I'll beat my three
minute Mark I hope um
the auto dealers as you know is a trade
Association representing the motor
vehicle industry we oppose House Bill
1237 uh for a couple specific Parts um
basically in line 15 um where it says
but shall not electronically capture
retain copy or place in a consumer file
any personal information from uh the
driver's license that personal
information is required for us to use um
uh to process a title application a
vehicle registration application um so
we we in fact need that um our lending
institutions require it of us um before
we're going to uh finance a significant
amount of money um a vehicle dealer also
really wants to know who you are before
you take one of their vehicles whether
it's a $6,000 car or a $60,000 Ram
pickup um and go for a test drive so
they take a copy of your driver's
license
um you can always
uh have that conversation with them if
you're not comfortable with surrendering
that information but the consumer offers
it up they know that you know in order
to test drive this vehicle we're going
to share that information with you
um our dealers are are subject to
complex Federal Regulations it's a real
regulatory maze is what we refer to um
with an alphabet soup of acronyms of um
regulating agencies but specifically
when it comes to the privacy and
safeguarding of consumer cons consumers
information we're subject to intense
Federal Regulations through the gram
leech B act um and they have significant
penalties um as well as operational
requirements uh you know many dealers
actually have on staff a compliance
officer um just to deal with both state
and federal regs but in this area um
we're subject to uh the federal um
privacy and safeguards role
um I'm assuming that there are many
other business organiz ations um opposed
to the bill as well um as you heard you
know the scanning of a driver's license
just is is so commonplace these days um
the other day I happened to walk into my
physical therapist's office and in order
to get in I had to scan my driver's
license on a scanner and then on the
iPad screen above it it told me which
room to go to and which doctor I would
be with negating the need for a
receptionist um but that's how it's done
at this particular physical therapist um
I can attest to the same thing at rental
car agencies checking in at the airport
um not to pick on anyone airline jet
blue requires you to scan your driver's
license in order to be able to check in
so
um so um with that being said um you
know um I want to remind you that we do
oppose the bill um however well intended
um and then when it comes to um
represent of Hill when it comes to the
issue of retaining the information there
are instances when retaining that
information is a good thing and I would
say when it comes to fraudulent or uh
what we deal with sometimes are called
straw man purchases where someone
purchases a vehicle for someone else
they then do something they're not
allowed to do like export the vehicle or
the vehicle is used in a crime sometimes
retaining that information can in fact
be helpful um for uh as mentioned fraud
or crime prevention um and then um
chairman Walsh to your point about
whether we'd be open to exploring the
issue with you all uh for for certain uh
industry exemptions um we would uh
welcome to be part of that discussion if
in fact that's what you choose to do and
it wouldn't be the first time that
discussion's been had uh I believe it
was a session or two ago there was a
bill in the Senate uh that dealt with
exemptions for stuff like this for uh
both retail vehicle dealers um and
importantly the bill stemmed from um the
medical community for the requiring of
of scan scanning so we would be open to
participating that discussion uh if you
so choose um so with that being said um
I'll kind of wrap up there and uh answer
any questions if there AR
any thank you you saved my question
representative St Clair thank you Mr
chair and thank you I I want to go to
your personal experience at your for
your physical what was it Physical
Therapy physical therapy so when you go
and you put the card or they scan the
card there's nobody there you can talk
to so this is to just replace having an
employee there I scanned my driver's
license and then the screen popped up
and said room 104 take a left Dr yeah I
just was curious if there was an
employee there okay thank you I'm sure
if there was a problem I could have
but well I know the proliferation of
scanning is out there as you said and
that's another example but have you ever
heard of William Penn I believe he said
wrong is wrong even if everybody is in
favor of it so let what this bill is
seeking to do any other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you very
much I'm going to close the public
1273 our next hearing is scheduled for
1:00 so do please I know we're a little
late if you can do your best to get here
by then we can try to start on time as
can
all right good afternoon
everybody I'm going to open up the
public hearing being 108 apologize for
being late the public hearing on House
Bill
1247 relative to motor uh nope uh
relative to requiring the display of
certain information concerning Selective
Service registration at driver's
licensing and school military recruiting
locations chair IES the prime sponsor
afternoon thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Tom Manion uh I'm representing Hillsboro
one
pelum I listed in the United States
Marine Corps in 2004 and despite scoring
a perfect score of 99 on the am Aron
service vocational aptitude battery and
my recruiter insisting I could do any
job I wanted I chose to join the
Infantry I wanted to be the first to
fight I wanted to fine and kill those
responsible for September 11th attacks
my patriotism was supercharged and I
would do anything for my country I never
got a chance to go after Bin Laden
instead I was deployed to Iraq twice I
didn't understand foreign policy and I
believed the propaganda about Li uh ties
to 911 and weapons of mass
destruction uh I deployed with Third
Battalion six Marines and took part in
operations Iron Fist and Steel Curtain
in the alheim region in the al-anbar
province along the Syrian
border we never found weapons of mass
destruction only a growing Insurgency
that resented our presence contrary to
the claims of the news media that the
Iraqi people would welcome us with open
arms as liberators we now know today
that the Iraq War was based on lies my
patriotism was exploited for these lies
and I watched friends of mine get killed
and maimed by vbieds mortar strikes
Small Arms fire and for
what a chunk of Iraq fell to Isis
because we decimated the country's
ability to defend itself we then had to
go back in and clean up the mess we made
and we are remaining there to this day
despite protests of the Dem
democratically elected government do we
support democracy in Iraq or don't we I
can't speak to the experiences of those
that served in Afghanistan but the
outcome there is not very different 20
years thousands of lives trillions of
dollars to take the country from the
Taliban and return it to the Taliban
there's a union leader article written
about this bill and I want to address
their complaints verely they mention our
victory over Isis which is an
organization that would never have
existed if we didn't invade Iraq and
ferment rebellion in Syria against
Bashar al-assad the moderate Rebels we
trained in the early days of the Syrian
Civil War helped form
Isis so if the author wants to put uh to
P for us to Pat ourselves on the back
for killing an enemy we created that's
like congratulating yourself for putting
out a kitchen fire you started while
admiring the ashes the article then goes
on to claim that the massive military
campaign in in Afghanistan was a
prerequisite to having a staging point
to the to then execute the Seal team
mission in Jal alabad Pakistan and Ally
nation of ours to get Bin Laden yet we
remained in Afghanistan for another
decade following his death for what
purpose intelligence agencies located
Bin Laden independent of military
operations in Afghanistan where our men
were getting killed by roadside bombs
and hit and run Taliban
strikes would it not have been easier to
utilize those same elligence assets and
precision missions for the entirety of
the global war on terror the enemy was
not a nation state but then again the
military-industrial complex can't make
money that way Pew research did a study
in 2019 that found that only 33% of
veterans believe the Iraq War was worth
fighting and only 38% believe the
Afghanistan war was worth fighting and
this study was conducted before the
disastrous pull out and the Taliban
immediately retaking control I imagine
that number is significantly lower
I have noticed a generational Gap with
regards to anti-war efforts in the
veterans community our own State
veterans advisory committee has opposed
all three anti-war bills I've
co-sponsored this turn and this is
something I plan on addressing in 2025
as there's no way 20 different veteran
organiz organizations voting and lock
step in favor of the war machine as
representative of the veteran Community
as a whole because it discounts the
massive growing anti-war veteran
population out there including
myself but setting aside military
members I ask a question to the parents
out there would you support your child
or grandchild dying for microchips in
Taiwan or for regime change in
Iran or you for Ukraine in any
context we have a long history of
transparency in the Granite State this
bill hopes to give greater context to
what teenagers will be enlisting to
support the fact that veteran
organizations are taking the point in
opposition on behalf of the Department
of Defense shows was a desire to keep
inconvenient facts hidden there was a
suggestion in my email to add the
positives of enlisting but the purpose
of this bill is to provide a
Counterpoint to the recruiters who are
already telling half the story which was
an AC
accusation this bill's critics are
levying at me the belief that there is
potential recruit the belief is that if
potential recruits get the full picture
it would hurt recruiting and that
Omission is required to get teenagers to
sign up and with that I ask committees
to vote OTP on hb1 1246 I want to note
there's an error in the bill uh By the
time OLS got this back it was past the
deadline the uh the line about the
casualty figures in Afghanistan needs to
be corrected that late drafting is also
why I was not able to get any
co-sponsors but I did have a bunch lined
up there's a good group of anti-war
people in the State
House thank you sir questions from the
committee representative
sers I want to just be clear did what
Bill did you say 1247 yeah okay this
just
my further questions from the committee
representative
C thank you Mr chairman thank you for
question uh you say there are some
updated numbers I yes there the
Afghanistan figures are tenfold
increased there's a extra zero at the
end that needs to be stripped off do you
have that information or can that be
forwarded to the committee I can
absolutely forward it to the committee I
can even help draft an amendment to
correct it okay thank you anything else
that you
any followup followup followup okay is
there any any other item in the bill
that you think needs adjusting it was
just that just that text from what I
could tell thank
you further questions from the committee
you uh next up chair will
[Music]
recognize Brendan Finn State veterans
Council uh oppos to the bill um looking
for five to 10
minutes five would be better three' be
even better than
that welcome thank you I'd like to uh
defer to Major General nikitis and if I
may speak after him would that be
acceptable to the
chair you can both take the table at the
like so the sh recognizes as well
uh David mtis
the Hampshire National Guard also
opposed to the committee I mean opposed
to the
apologize Mr chair committee members for
the record on Major General David madus
the ad general for the New Hampshire
National Guards uh commissioner theart
Department of military Affairs and
veteran
services um I'm going to paraphrase my
written testimony for you today the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services opposes Health Bill
1247 this bill requires a form to be
available at State driers Licensing
locations and at schools hosting
military recruiters concerning
registration with the Selective Service
System it claims that the information
included in this bill provides
transparency and military
recruiting this one-sided and decidedly
biased Bill attempts to influence the
next GR generation of Americans from the
joining Mage service is a viable career
path for requiring the display of CAS
information from Global warant teror at
these driver relection St sets and
military recruiting offices the
department believes that the principles
of transparency would dictate a full and
honest assessment of all the facts
information and content to ensure an
informed and Equitable decision
regarding transparency this bill falls
short the information required by this
bill fails to exol the virtues and value
of military service as an honorable
profession left as is this one-sided and
bias buil that attempts to improve
transparency in military recruiting
would immedately have an impact adverse
impact on the Department's defense
ability to recruit and maintain a RC
capable all volunteer military force it
indirectly implies that all those who
have served our military veterans have
not earned or achieved anything positive
through their military service that
benefits their employer their families
of
society the major concern with this bill
is its most assur adverse impact of
recruiting the information required to
be displayed by this bill is less about
transparency and more about dissuading
men and women from concering military
service our national security depends on
a strong capable and all volunteer Force
if pass this bill were serve to weaken
efforts to recruit train equip and
maintain that
Force locally by persuading today's
youth against seeking military service
as a pathway to a successful career it
would have a disastrous effect on the in
Hampshire National guard in our ability
to recruit and sustain our all volunteer
Force the National Guard's primary
domestic mission is this simple save
lives mitigate human suffering and
prevent the loss of damage of personal
property do we forget two years ago that
over 800 service members were activated
in the state of New Hampshire to serve
the citizens of the state during the
global pandemic
800 we do search and rescue we do uh we
supported the state prison during the co
pandemic
we provided 281,000 meals for the New
Hampshire food bank we handled 56,000
calls to the unemployment security
office we drove 373,000 miles delivering
177,000 uh medical PPE orders we LED
vaccination sites we've administered
over 800,000
vaccines that's what you will not be
getting every year our aviators conduct
countless surf and rescue operations
throughout New Hampshire our counterdrug
program supports Municipal and state law
enforcement against the plague of drug
overdoses and our Civ civil support team
supports municipal fire departments and
state Partners in mitigating any
hazardous threats to our state since our
Inception in 1679 when called upon by
the citizens of New Hampshire the
National Guard motto is always ready
always there without the ability to fill
our formations with an all with the next
greatest generation of service members
ability to fulfill our duty to New
Hampshire will simply not exist this
bill is not about transparency is a
one-sided biased campaign against a
small segment of our society that
provides an invaluable service to our
community State and Nation this
information is required to be displayed
and not a full accounting of the facts
if pass this bill will Ser seriously
jeopardize the ability to recruit in
strong andc capable all volunteer Force
I strongly encourage the members of the
committee to find House Bill 1247
inexpedient to
legislate subject to their questions
that's all I have any question from the
sers thank you Mr chair someone's got to
ask the
questions thank you Major General um my
question to you is is anything that's
printed on this bill is it inaccurate
yes could you point that out for us the
list of the number of uh uh service
members called in Afghanistan
was the primary one he added in
zero the questions from the committee
for the major
general representative
C I don't have a question but I just
want to say thank you for your service
thank you ma'am with no other questions
representative
s yes sir um those positives that you
outlined um are they in your written
written testimony yes sir okay I I just
want to make sure we have a copy of it
thank you sir I think we're just Lost in
Translation is every service member
swears an not through the Constitution
to prce Nation against all enemies
enemies forn and domestic it's that
simple I don't dictate where we go and
for why we go I'm here to serve the
citizens of the state and the citizens
less with no other question floor is
yours thank you sir thank General my
name is Brendan Finn I serve on the
state veterans Council and I'm a
lieutenant Colonel and the Marine Corps
Reserve uh I like the sponsor of this
bill I joined shortly after 911 I
intended to fight in support of uh the
war in Iraq and I ended up in
Afghanistan so kind of the opposite of
his experience and I'll be speaking from
that experience and the experience I had
leading Marines and what military
service has given them and the benefits
that they've received and I'll do my
best to stick to that three minute time
frame if
possible the state veterans Council also
opposes House Bill 1247 because the bill
would deepen the current military
recruiting crisis it would dissuade
potential recruits from joining the
military expand the civilian military
divide and deny recruits that it would
dissuade the many benefits of military
service at a December 6 Senate armed
services Committee hearing Major General
Davis Commanding General of Army
Recruiting Command said this is one of
the toughest recruiting Landscapes I've
seen in over 33 years of service he and
his counterpart carts of the other uh
Services were describing the
circumstances that led the army my the
Navy and the Air Force to all fall short
of their recruiting goals in
2023 only 12% of potential recruits have
a parent who's a veteran as compared to
40% in
1995 additionally a 2020 defense
department study found that
77% of 17 to 24 year olds are ineligible
for military service due to obesity drug
use Andor physical mental health
problems if the military continues to
miss its recruiting goal s it'll be
unable to execute our national defense
strategy deter our adversaries and to
protect the US in its interest as
geopolitics shifts back to bipolarity
and the great power competition as China
prepares to Annex Taiwan and as Russia
and Iran are increasingly belligerent
Americans regarding the veteran suicide
statistic that the bill would require
that the state post I think we can all
agree that veteran suicide is far too
prevalent and that we should all work
together to address it I think we can
also agree that a fair description of
military service should include the
leadership comrad ship purpose life
skills and federal and state benefits
that it provides I've seen the benefits
of military service transform the lives
of Marines in 2009 I had the honor of
and privilege of leading a marine Recon
platoon in
Afghanistan I challenged one of my three
assistant team leaders a sergeant to
read his first book during that
deployment between operations we took
turns reading a book of short stories
and we discussed what we read between
operations uh we executed what I call a
tactical book club and after that
deployment he left the service and
entered a vocational program and became
a successful
welder another Marine in that same unit
used his post 911 GI bills to attend
Texas University or the University of
Texas at Austin from which he graduated
with 3.9 GPA in three
Majors another attended the University
of Maryland and completed a Bachelor of
Science Program in a cyber security
certificate through the GI Bill and he's
now a digital forensics expert at a
leading Healthcare technology company
yet another of that same platoon another
Junior Marine completed a mechanical
engineering bachelor's degree program at
the University of Missouri through the
GI program and he's now the CEO of a
product design company that he founded
every single one of that platoon's
senior enlisted Marines will have
retired as either a Gunnery Sergeant a
chief petty officer a first sergeant a
master sergeant and a Master Gunnery
Sergeant far from the path to ruin that
house bill 1247 biased and misleading
languager suggest military service for
my Marines and sailor enabled their
upward socioeconomic mobility and
self-actualization House Bill 1247 is
titled transparency in military
recruiting but it offers far less a
misrepresentation of military service
has a tragic misadventure in pursuit of
failed objectives worse the bill would
dissuade New Hampshire citizens from
serving exactly when the US military
most needs our help in finding the men
and women who will keep our nation safe
and free it would deepen the civilian
military divide already far too many
citizens think of those who served in
the military as broken instead of as
assets and their Community House Bill
1247 is biased and misleading language
would support their erroneous and
harmful preconceived notions New
Hampshire citizens have always
volunteered to serve our country which
has benefited them their communities and
our nation please ensure they always
will by finding House Bill 1247
inexpedient to legislate thank
you thank you questions from the
committee representative sers uh thank
you Mr chair and uh thank thank you for
taking my question um I also served in
the in the military and I appreciate the
GI bill and I used it and look at me now
year so you said two couple key words
you picked I want to pick up on is you
said miscellany language and also Mis uh
misrepresentation and that's why I'm
getting back to I want to make sure this
is truth and that's why I'm asking and I
ask Major
General and are there really any
inaccuracies here that are are misstated
are really exactly what you said in
those two things misleading or
misrepresentation well I think that you
can hold up a you could cover half a
portrait and say is this the portrait
and the answer is well it's half of it
that's accurate information except for
the Casual statistics in Afghanistan
which I just learned about however I
think that it does not in any way
describe the whole now the sponsor of
this bill mentioned that he assumes that
recruiters are giving the second half of
that picture but that's an assumption
some recruiters may be some may not some
may be giving the full picture and then
the negatives are being reemphasized by
this bill's language so I think it would
be much better for the state to put
itself in a position of providing a
holistic view of military service rather
than just
half yep followup thank you Mr chair
would it be helpful uh to give a better
representation by saying during these
these years we also had you know uh
680,000 people sign up to serve with
that help in balancing the
numbers I think the more information the
better I think that this one this the
current draft of the bill provides a
very misleading picture and if we can
only improve upon it um I think that if
you were to look at the experience of my
Marines who were in Afghanistan fighting
that war that the sponsor of this bill
deemed a failure they would look back on
our entire experience as positive and
our experiences which I do not think our
misrepresentative or are uh misleading
sample would suggest that there are a
great deal of benefits to serving the
military even in pursuit of objectives
that um one person might deem to be
failed just for my own S I do want to
make sure every I made a lot of money
during the years from that GI bill so
follow
up uh any other questions from the
committee seeing nothing thank you both
you uh next up chair recognizes Brooks
Hayward uh New Hampshire National Guard
afternoon
thank you very much
sir next up chair recognize
that James Adams uh not saying who it
represents also opposed to the
ient yeah hold on if I can yeah we have
microphones nowadays if I can get you to
introduce yourself and uh start my name
is Jim Adam
I'm the chairman of the state veterans
Council and there's very little I can
add to what the general and Brendon gave
you for information I
think the biggest concern that we have
is is Brendan may this is one man's
opinion and he's put in all
negative items to represent his opinion
and in a world
where right now we've got two active
shooting Wars to say we're uh almost in
1939 all over again might not be too
much of an exaggeration but the bottom
line is is the last thing we need is not
being able to get
volunteers and with the complete
volunteer service something like this
would be
far um it would just be too much for us
to overcome not overcome but it's it's
just very very poor and I I really
believe that and and uh I went through
my some of my readings and by the way I
am a Vietnam
veteran and when we came home we got a
pretty rough welcome but some of that
was deserved because it was a very uh
very poorly thought out event over there
but the veterans that I serve or and I'm
in the chapter 41 here in conquer of the
Vietnam Veterans of America it's amazing
that all we went through coming home and
all we went through over there that a
full 90% of those veterans are proud of
what they did they've did what their
country asked and they fought for their
country and amazingly old fuds like me
66% of them if they're called are ready
to go tomorrow now we know that won't
happen but I believe that that the state
veterans Council and so many of the
other organizations here New Hampshire's
veterans community is one of the most
outstanding in the country country and
the words I I remember from Ronald
Reagan for the Fallen not to be
forgotten we must be their voice and the
veterans voice in New Hampshire is
outstanding and loud and it is very much
against this bill we don't this is the
time we need to start pulling together
not to start to point out that
somebody's got a a hole in their sock so
thank you very much for your time thank
you very much any questions from the
committee I see one if you'll take it
yes representative
V I'm
very uh downtrodden I guess I don't know
very depressed by this this bill in a
lot of ways because almost every
conflict since in US history has had
people questioning the motivation behind
it has always been a question of you
know going even world two world wars is
it is it fair to for the state to step
in and and try to tip the scale in one
way or the other on on opinions of how
these these conflicts were handled
whether they were VI valid reasons or
whether we R Li to is it is it possible
that there you know I guess that would
be a followup but I won't do that but is
it fair to do this from the state level
in this
context I believe that your spot on this
is not an issue for the state to decide
did we win lose or draw is it one one
and one in our last three
Wars exactly this is this is I in my
humble belief people will make up their
minds but I I think I'd like to leave
you with the fact that that I've had the
privilege of of working with and being
with veterans all of my life and most of
them say after it was the best job they
ever had and every one of those men and
women realized that when they sign up
they sign a blank check leading up to an
including giving their lives
for what we have today that's an
outstanding country and my opinion in
this state has always been there to go
forward follow yeah I I just want to
make sure I thank you for your service
and thank all the veterans who you know
right or wrong they showed up for
service for their country at the request
of their country and and you
know I understand the history of the
United States I understand how they can
be conflicts and I appreciate it I just
want to make sure I say that thank you
very much
much thank you Tom further questions
from the committee seeing n thank you
very much sir thank
you uh next up chair recognizes Kevin
Grady representing the state veterans
advisory committee opposed to the bill
sir good afternoon Mr chairman ladies
and gentlemen of the committee I did
come see you all last week so I've have
some recency here I do rep uh my for the
record my name is Kevin Grady I'm a 25
year Air Force veteran and I'm also a
25e resident of the town of hooks at New
Hampshire today I'm here representing
the 20 member organizations of the state
veterans advisory committee uh we
unanimously opposed this bill there was
no discussion whatsoever of this bill
when we had our meeting on it on the 2nd
of January uh we just made a motion to
oppose and it was unanimous across the
board uh to oppose the bill since the
representative brought it up I don't
want to leave you with the int with the
idea that we on the state veterans
advisory committee are a bunch of old
school Lackey of the military industrial
complex okay uh the three bills that he
individually sponsored that we oppose
that he's upset about are number one
house bill
229 and that and this bill and the other
Bill to some degree we have the same
complaint with all of them and the same
complaint is Schoolhouse Rock okay
Schoolhouse Rock supremacy clause of the
Constitution okay when you have a
federal law you can't make a state law
that that conflicts with the federal law
you can't do it it says so right in
Schoolhouse Rock I learned that when I
was I was younger okay so House Bill 229
on not deploying the guard in case uh
unless there's a declaration of war it
flies in the face of what's written in
plain black and white in English in
title 10 of US law and that's why we
oppose it you know the reason why is
because in the military we're rule
followers when you make a rule we tend
to follow it okay the other two this
this session House Bill
1338 which was sort of attacking and
deciding we weren't going to do anything
with the Selective Service um is again
misplaced if you want to get rid of The
Selective Service and let's be honest we
haven't drafted anybody in this country
since I was a sophomore at the Air Force
Academy a long time ago in a galaxy Far
Far Away more than 50 years since we've
drafted anybody in our country if you
want to do that the way to do that is we
ask our Congressional Delegation to
introduce legislation in Washington DC
and either say selective service is
something whose time is come and gone or
we decide to make it Equitable say if
we're going to require our young men to
register we should require our young
ladies to register too so you can do one
of those two things what you can't do is
pass a law at the state level that says
we're just going to Gap up with the
federal laws are and that has been our
objection to those two bills and this
one okay this bill is is in your
committee primarily because the
Selective Service piece of this thing uh
asked that they put this information
available in uh the where the driver's
license bureaus are in the DMV that's
why you're hearing this bill as opposed
to state federal relations in military
Affairs for
example so that those are the reasons
why primarily we oppose this you've
heard a lot about military recruiting
and I just want to leave you with this
thought about military recruiting we're
all competing out there for the best
talent available on the civilian side on
the military side we're dealing with
historically low unemployment in the
state of New Hampshire I'm not telling
any of you anything that you don't
already know on that and because the old
school teacher and me always likes to
cite his sources okay I'm going to cite
this Source it's not my opinion it's the
opinion of chief Master Sergeant of the
Air Force Joanne bass my wife and I
watched a a fireside chat with uh the uh
president of the Air Force Association
uh and her and she's a very sharp person
I I highly recommend you you look into
her but what she said was 10 years
ago
Walmart Dunkin
Donuts for their people that are not
hourly help there was no such thing as a
benefits package now they all have a
benefit benefits package okay we have
benefits in the military but paying
allowances there's not much we can do
about that except at the federal level
so you know it when you write a bill
like this that that it just makes the
the job of these folks who have already
talked to you about that harder uh to do
and that's all I really wanted to tell
you this this afternoon and subject to
your questions I'll get out of your
hair yeah thank you very much sir any
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you uh representative pondon thank
you I I just uh for the record I would
be remiss for not thanking all the
representatives who spoke and today that
served our country and defended our
constitution it means a lot in this room
and I just want to say thank you for the
record thank you sir it was my honor to
serve further questions seeing none
thank you
again I have nobody else signed up to
speak uh so I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 1247 7 uh
just a couple of moments to regroup and
next
I was just coming to tell you the close
is
clear I was out there listening to
everything
SC still can't figure out how I could
swing and
spin
spe
good afternoon I'm going to open up the
public
hearing if I can get your attention
please we going to open up the public
hearing on House Bill 1244 prohibited
smoking and ecigarettes and Motor
Vehicles when a passenger is under 16
years of age chair recognized as the
prime sponsor representative Schmid good
afternoon good afternoon Mr chairman
thank you for your welcome um when I
joined the legislature 21 years ago the
first bill I sponsored was before the
transportation committee and I think it
I haven't been there that many times
this the chairman at that time was our
current current Speaker Sherman
Packard um so after dealing with me he
went right to the
top uh thank you very much and and uh I
I brought this bill uh before uh because
uhbe sorry about
that certainly not you're doing Mr
chairman but thank you having for having
the door closed uh it's tough
competition when you got a lot of of
background noise uh
uh s smoke is uh is not just an
irritation to many of us I I have a lot
of problem when I uh am in a car where
there's been smoking going on or even if
somebody's coming toward me sometime and
I and I'm they're
smoking and when I go past them and so
forth I can smell the smoke in the air
all the way 50 feet behind them so forth
so it's persistent and it's not not only
an irritation I'm sure as many of you
know it's also a tremendous Health uh
Hazard um and when it's concentrated in
a
vehicle uh perhaps in a time when the
windows can't be opened uh and their
children present it's more than an
irritation but are captives in that
vehicle we require them to be belted in
uh at you certain ages um and if they're
in that vehicle they are being subjected
to a a a toxic element which is very
deleterious to their health um so I've
long believed that uh that smoking in
vehicles should be prohibited uh for the
same reason that that we don't let
children uh you know
sit unb belted because in case of an
accident they're a tremendous Hazard
with small bodies in many cases um so uh
and this bill has been before this
committee uh several times and and it's
also been favorably uh reviewed by this
committee and I think several times it's
been uh passed with an or reported out
with an autop pass or sometimes
otpa um so I'm not going to the major
Advocate uh for this bill here today
because uh there's several young people
here behind me from the do youth to
Youth
Organization uh which I've been a
longtime fan of because it's an
excellent training for young people to
advocate for issues and they frequently
sponsor bills couple of times they've
sponsored this co-sponsored this bill or
supported this bill for me uh but also
in another cases and uh they're the ones
that are most at risk um because if you
have a child in a in a vehicle and there
the adult is at the wheel smoking or
maybe sitting in a passenger seat kids
are they're stuck for the duration of
that trip in that car so uh I'll answer
a question or two if you have any but I
really want you to listen to the young
people from Dover uh whove come to speak
today to speak to you today so with that
I'll end my testimony except try to
answer any of the questions you may
have thank you representative St Clair
thank you Mr chair thank you um do you
have a number of is there a number of
states that already have a law like this
uh on the
books I I haven't even investigated
because I represent New Hampshire this
is the only state that I have any
influence on although I you you know I I
could I have relatives in a bunch of the
Midwest states I came from 45 years ago
um but uh I have no idea whe it's even
been brought forward in other in other
states all right thank
you further questions from the
committee let's start with somebody new
representative
sellers thank you Mr chair I thought
you're gonna surely pick somebody else
um I'm going back 55 years 60 years even
and my parents smoked in the vehicles we
had station wagons the back window
opened up we've breathed all this stuff
in and I'm not saying I'm proud of it
but I'm saying it might cause harm but
it's it's not necessarily deadly and and
and my point
is you're G to force everybody that
smokes just because they have a child in
the car they're going to be you're
telling them that they can't smoke at if
the kids are under 16 that's that's what
you're telling them that's what you want
that is what I want
yes I think that was a question uh
representative
Jones thank you um just for my
information is flavored vaping
considered ecigarette are they is that
under the same category is there
anything so
yeah represent
pondon thank you um representative i f
may ask how do you envision uh
enforcement on on this issue uh as an
example would this give police the the
jurisdiction to pull a vehicle over if
they see someone smoking and assume
there's a a juvenile in the in the
vehicle and also next part of my
question would be um how will we ID the
juvenile as well just some looking for
some
thoughts well uh the way I usually
recognize identified juveniles is by
looking at them because uh whereas a 16
or 17y old can uh look like an adult um
the uh obviously young children are very
obviously children uh they don't they
don't have any IDs but the the Bill
calls for uh for if people are under 16
and some 16y olds are pretty good size
and and pretty adultlooking um but uh
the the bottom line here is the first
part of your question which is can a
police officer pull a vehicle over and
if you look at the second part of the
bill you see that it says it's a
secondary offense so it can't stop the
vehicle for uh for smoking only but
rather uh if if they're being stopped
for something else and the police
officer observes that there are children
present and smoking going on then as a
secondary offense he can uh he can site
instance not seeing any other questions
thank you very much thank you very much
attention okay now I have a pink card
with three names on it did you all want
to come up at
Louisa peler Megan
merrian and Eleanor I can't make out the
last one Germaine
German when you come on up just and say
your names for the record now that we're
on YouTube everybody on the planet needs
to
know and you are all supporting the bill
welcome hello my name is Louisa peler my
name is Megan Moran my name is Elanor
Gorman and we are are all members of do
youth's Youth and do youth's youth is a
drug and alcohol prevention organization
based in do New Hampshire we have 60
plus members who meet in four different
groups to plan and conduct prevention
projects within our community we are
here today in favor of HB
1244 the impact of secondhand smoke also
referred to as shs is increased when the
child or and smoker are in a confined
space such as a vehicle the closed
location traps the dangerous chemicals
and toxins in the vehicle and
subsequently affects the occupants in a
notably more harmful
way so as we said earlier one of our
biggest concerns is the health concerns
of secondhand smoke which is also known
as environmental tobacco smoke
secondhand smoke can affect natural
development of kids lungs and can cause
long-term if not permanent damage
tobacco smoke contains over 4,000
chemicals at least 96 of which can cause
different kinds of cancer including lung
cancer
Leukemia secondhand smoke is also linked
to various diseases and illnesses such
as asthma and lower respiratory tract
infections almost 1 million asmatic kids
in the US suffer from increased problems
due to secondhand smoke exposure the EPA
states that secondhand smoke increases
the number of asthma attacks and
severity of asthma related
issues we would additionally like to
address the belief that rolling down the
window will prevent harm to people in
the vehicle opening a window reduces the
harm but does not eliminate it
sufficiently according to the American
non-smokers rights Foundation when
someone smokes in the small enclosed
space of a car or other vehicle people
breathe toxic Air at levels many times
higher than what the EPA considers
hazardous even when a window is
down in 2006 a study was conducted by
the Harvard School of Public Health
meant to measure the toxicity of
secondhand smoking cars researchers
found that even with the driver's
windows
open the amount of secondhand smoke in
the car is approximately seven times
higher than the epa's Hazardous level
according to the EP air is considered
unhealthy with sensitive groups such as
children and elderly when secondhand
smoke concentrations are about 40
microgram per cubic meter in the study
the air reached a level of 272
micrograms and a peak of 5505 micrograms
per cubic meter these results show that
smoking in the car can result in
extremely harmful levels of secondhand
smoke especially for Children and Youth
now we also have concerns surrounding
the Lesser known issue of thirdhand
smoke third hand smoke is an issue in
which the chemicals and toxin toxins
from cigarettes and Vapes coat surfaces
or absorbed into Fabrics or other
materials such as curtains these
chemicals can then be picked up by kids
as they touch surfaces and put their
hands or fingers within their mouth the
digestion or inhalation of these
residual chemicals can be extremely
dangerous
extending beyond the issue of just
traditional cigarettes we also want to
raise concerns about the use of Vapes
and ecigarette products in enclosed
spaces despite having only been on the
market for roughly 15 years much of the
research done on Vapes and ecigarettes
has indicated there is a serious concern
with secondhand Vapor Dr tat Islam a
leading re researcher on secondhand
Vapor has found that exposure to
secondhand aerosols from ecigarettes is
associated with increased risk of
bronchitis system and shortness of
breath among young adults in addition to
nicotine the aerosols include heavy
metals such as lead nickel and zinc
cancer causing substances such as
Benzene and Dietl which has been linked
with a condition nicknamed popcorn lung
Vape other states have passed this bill
or similar ones as well including
Illinois Vermont Arkansas California
Virginia Louisiana Oregon and Utah for
example in the state of Illinois it is
illegal to smoke in the car with
children under the age of
18 although you might feel this is
specifically targeting parents we don't
want anyone to feel that we are
attacking parents this law is meant to
also protect children from potentially
dangerous decisions made by grandparents
babysitters uncles neighbors Uber
drivers and family friends young kids in
a car with a grandparent neighbor or
parent are unable to control their
environment they are not in charge and
have no way to stop their exposure and
often will not even realize that they
are being exposed to harmful
substances these children may even be
defenseless and strapped into a car seat
take a moment to imagine a 2-year-old
strapped into their car seat in the back
of their brother's car the brother pulls
out a cigarette and starts smoking the
smoke then pulls in the back seat
forcing this helpless child oblivious to
the consequences and unable to advocate
for their own health to breathe in
numerous toxic chemicals this child is
exposed to many health-threatening
chemicals that open up a door for
diseases and conditions later in
life you can make a statement by passing
this bill we believe that the Youth of
New Hampshire our age and especially
younger should have the freedom to live
a healthy life with all this being said
we strongly encourage you to vote in
favor of house bill till
12:44 thank you for your time and we
would be happy to answer any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions from the
committee representative
dumes how was this bill
enforcable so uh thank you so much for
your question uh so in New Hampshire we
actually have a lot about um cell phone
usage and texting driving uh you're not
allowed to do that in New Hampshire and
I think it would be very uh along
similar lines as to that um I you see
people on their phones that would be a
thing where police officers would be
able to pull them over uh I think it was
referenced earlier where they talked
about you can clearly visibly tell when
a child is a child um and I think it
would be similar guidelines under that
agree representative St Clair did you
still have your hand up I do thank you
Mr chair
um I be I just would like to know do you
have hear from a lot of your friends uh
ever complaining about their parents
doing this or uh you know smoking while
you're in the car your friends are in
the car or uh even other adults and then
I have a
followup uh yes I I know people whose
parents smoke in the car and I think
many people our age um the school that
we attend they've taken out a lot of the
presentations on drug misuse because
they're like oh we cover it in health
class but they really don't so I think
that the youth in New Hampshire are
relatively uneducated on this topic and
therefore are unaware of all the co
conditions and diseases that could be
caused by this exposure and I think it's
important to one educate them and two
help protect them from these potential
dangerous
choices follow up yep follow up thank
you
and
um the student on the on on my left
there uh she read you read a number of
states that have a similar law and you I
was trying to count and I couldn't but
could you just give me the total number
on that I believe it's
eight eight eight okay thank you oh you
have the testim and then I would also
like to address rep sell's comment um
and correct me if I'm incorrect earlier
you said that uh you grew up and with
secondhand smoke and you aren't
necessarily saying that smoking is not
bad that was not your statement but more
so that people aren't dying due to
secondhand smoke is that
correct uh yeah that's that's not how
this works you don't I just wanted to
you're not he's not your witness I just
wanted to I didn't want to miss I didn't
want to misspeak on what he was saying
because I did want to make an additional
comment that I didn't make earlier again
we try not to get back and force of
course no I would never do that um but I
I did want to point out that this is a
big issue that we have um I know Eleanor
and Megan are members of the do you
youth as well as I am but they are they
are currently attending over middle
school and I attend over High School uh
and I remember so many of my friends
parents and struggling uh with smoking
and I remember so many many of my
friends were made fun of for having
clothes with that smelled like smoke and
things like that and being ridiculed
because of that uh which is truly just
heartbreaking it's hard enough being in
high school and being in Middle School
figuring out who you are and then having
another thing to be made fun of um but I
would like to acknowledge that since
1964 2 and a half million people have
died due to health related issues with
secondhand smoke uh and many of those
people are people's parents siblings
brothers sisters and I think that's
important to
know any further questions from the
committee representative Gorski thank
you Mr chairman first of all I want to
acknowledge you all you three for for
doing this I think it's fantastic having
the youth coming in and and talking at a
bill so I want to congratulate you all
for doing this my question
is I have friends who are
smokers what would you say to them
when they say here I have a
car and if we pass this bill what would
you say to them in which they say you're
infringing on my right to be able to
drive my car and smoke my cigarette what
would you say to those people well first
we I just like to address that we don't
we're not attacking people who smoke
here we are attacking the industry and
their deliberate deception that is done
just to make money because tobacco
nicotine in any form is not good for
anybody but we would probably say to
them that we're not infringing on their
right to smoke in a vehicle at all times
we want to protect the Youth of New
Hampshire and protect them from all the
dangers that can be caused by by these
well seeing no other questions I want to
thank you very much thank you thank you
and without anybody else signed up to
speak I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill
12:44 uh just a few minutes to reset and
see
course
different
Wonder
up
okay welcome back I'm G to open up the
public hearing on House Bill 1467
relative to child passenger protection I
did get an email from the prime sponsor
who cannot make it today but
representative Horgan has been kind
enough to fill in for her welcome
representative
Oregon I won't be able to I mean nobody
can replace representative Gibbons he
would have been a what stronger
spokesman than I'll be but I'll I'll do
my best to introduce the bill so my name
is represent Timothy Horan from straford
County District 10 which is the town
town of Durham and I'm uh here B to very
uh quickly introduce hb1 1467 relative
to child passenger protection so it
upgrades the basically the uh the seat
belt laws as a regard to persons under
18 so persons over 18 are still uh free
to drive without their seat belts on um
that's you know that's a topic for for
another bill it
would if we had a hearing on that it
would probably be in rep's hall or at
least down the hall at the big Finance
room rather than in this little half
room so
um and um even if she had been and most
is a most was fairly self-explanatory
there's a
uh one thing was a topic that's been in
my my mind was this addresses that isn't
listed at all in the existing laws the
issue of older vehicles which so are so
old they weren't um equipped with seat
belts and I happen to have a friend who
died this summer actually I didn't
really know him that well his sister
mostly the brother of a friend of mine
who died uh tragically because he was
driving down I think route 106 in Wolf
Barrow a minor routine traffic acent
turned into tragedy because he was not
wearing a seat belt because after lar
didn't have one and
um there could be legislation to clarify
that of the law but that this that that
this only applies uh to people who are
under 18 who are riding in vehicles
including those with seat belts and
those without and it makes
um it I guess it's less Sweeping in the
past bill we had a past build that be
three years ago became very very
controversial it's about rear-facing
child seats so it does keep it does
mandate rear facing child seats
basically for children less than 2 years
old and uh weighing less than 30 PBS and
he can also use a rear facing child seat
for an older child uh who's under four
and weighing less than than 40 lb and
then there's other restrictions uh N I
suppose some adults are shorter than 4
foot n but um then they uh they can
still be in a uh child restraint system
unless they're big enough and then they
can unless they can um then then if they
need a booster seat they have to wear
that or at least at a minimum they have
to be belted in if they they meet
certain requirements um so I'm not going
to do anything more about antiqu cars
this year we may be seeing that next
year if I'm reelected if I go through
the idea but you may need a change to
the section
1-c which is
a which is about Vehicles equipped with
front seats and back seats that way this
is written that completely replaces
three sub chapters of let's see RSA 265
107a so 1 C I noticed has some um has
some exceptions in it which most you
probably uh which you probably want to
keep as is about uh there's some things
in there about like if it's a school bus
or if a child has an individual
education program which says he can't
here she can't be restrained or an
antique vehicles I mentioned here so we
want to
keep so probably need to add some some
of that at least some of that stuff back
in the section one desk see especially
in Roman numeral 2 I'm sure you've all
got the law books in front of me like I
do no just kidding but when you have a
work session um you'll have to you may
have to address that one well that's
actually uh well that's actually a
section two so anyway so you you may so
you actually maybe you don't need to
maybe you don't need to amend the law
you can just pass it as is so that's um
that's basically uh that's basically the
bill you would have had much better
explanation from representative Gibbons
but she can't be here because she has a
actual job outside the legislature and
whereas I'm a little bit more flexible
so I'm here so um I'd be happy to answer
any questions if you think I could
answer
them thank you very
much I do see a question I don't know
how anybody could have any but
representative Jones yeah no it's a
statement to you
okay uh a question or
statement the primary sponsor was your
earlier she nurse got called to work but
you leave free handouts yes everyone's
task I was going to make sure everybody
got those but I do believe they did okay
great thanks thanks for remembering that
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
you believe it or not that's all I have
signed up to speak on house bills 1467
so I'll close the public
hearing and from as behind as we were to
now caught up with some time to spare uh
I our next public hearing and last one
of this bium for house bills uh is at
2:30 House Bill
minutes
actually while we are waiting so you
know I cannot start early I've got it
posted in the calendar 2:30 um but I
need some people to defend our committee
reports for this coming Thursday uh we
numbers I'm looking for somebody to
defend the committee report on the
license suspension the one that matches
ohrv and
snowmobiles to Motor Vehicles if you
caught driving under suspension it was
I was one of the three so I can't be
speaking against the committee report so
I just need somebody that voted on the
prevailing side that would like to take
this to the floor so if you want to
think about it for a few minutes if I
can get a name of a volunteer from the
committee that voted favorably for it
that would be helpful I hate to have to
joke
all right welcome back everybody being
2:30 on the money I'm going to open up
the public hearing on House Bill 1457 FN
establishing penalties for driving over
covered wooden bridges and vehicles that
exceed posted limits and for vehicular
damage to covered wooden bridges uh
chair recognizes the prime
sponsor representative
transportation
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
to the committee I'm really excited to
be here about this
bill for the record I'm representative
Margaret dry I serve Sullivan district 7
which includes the towns of Newport
Unity Charlestown planfield and Cornish
the home of the iconic Cornish Windsor
Covered Bridge across the Connecticut
River also the largest and long oldest
the covered bridges of New Hampshire are
both historic and iconic and they're
beautiful a couple years ago I watched
the French console come up from Boston
to watch the unveiling of a marker for
his countryman Lafayette who crossed the
Cornish Windsor covered bridge on his
reunion tour about 200 years ago uh the
council paid no attention to the
unveiling because he was so busy looking
at the cover Bridge the Connecticut
River and the backdrop of M es scotney I
see tourists in front of this bridge uh
every season of the
year unfortunately the things that make
these Bridges so appealing are also uh
the things that make them susceptible to
damage they're not made of concrete and
steel they are from a simpler time and
they're really not made to accommodate
the kind of traffic that goes on them
today especially box trucks um um and uh
unfortunate GPS
systems uh this bill is designed to
increase the penalties for damage to
covered bridges stemming from violating
height weight or dimensional
limits the sponsors of these bills uh
all have covered bridges of this bill um
all have covered bridges in their
districts and I think each one of them
has a horror story about damage to the
bridge in their District I want to just
go through the bill with you really
quickly and
tell you what it what it
entails in section one Roman numeral one
uh this covers most of the stories that
make the news this is the visible damage
like broken Rafters or damages to walls
that you would see and what it does is
it raises the fine of the offense up to
uh uh $1,000 and if it the offense
substantially impedes the flow of ta
traffic the fine can be up to
$2,000 neurom mineral 2 talks about the
damage that is not immediately visible
and this came because of the request of
the lime police chief uh he says
overweight Vehicles go through their
covered bridge on River Road uh all the
time there's no debris left behind but
the wear and tear on the planks is such
that when he goes to the town meeting
this year he's going to ask for 600 or 7
$100,000 to repair the
bridge Roman numeral um these well this
is a little bit lower
fine but it can be up to $2,000 if it
impedes traffic and we got these numbers
um by a lot of research the original
story of why the bill came uh to pass I
will leave to the police chief from
Cornish and I don't want to steal his
Thunder but the model for this
legislation came after a sum's worth of
research last year from legislative
Services we looked at all the states
that had covered bridges uh from
Virginia Pennsylvania Ohio Maine Vermont
to see if anybody had legislation like
we would like to have and what we found
was that Vermont though very recent had
something that we would like to model
and so I spoke to the um gentleman who
sponsored that legislation in Vermont he
told us how they arrived at their
decisions and what the effects have been
uh in 201 22 they passed they raised the
fine to
$1,000 um up to 2,000 if it impedes
traffic and double for uh a repeat
offense um they also uh in the next year
found that the only town that had had a
a problem since they went into effect
was the town of lindenville and so they
because they have Dylan's rule were able
to allow the town of Lyndon to make its
own
uh fine and the town took them up on it
and they made it $5,000 for a First
Defense and 10,000 for a
second whoa yeah well they're not
messing around in Lyndon okay um and
they've had a lot of accidents on their
Bridge
uh the part three new Roman Newall 3
here just kind of elaborates uh why it's
important there's so many parts to a
covered bridge that can be damaged and
and can cause it can impede traffic and
be and just cause regular repairs to
that are maybe uh need to be done
quickly uh number Roman numeral four uh
the um the fine will be uh inured to the
municipality that has is responsible for
the bridge I didn't know this until I
started researching this but there are
five bridges in the state of New
Hampshire that the state maintains and
the Cornish Windsor bridge is one of
those but Cornish has other Bridges
covered bridges in in the town so um I
think it it was really fair that the
state would get the money from this
bridge and the town would get the money
from tickets for other
Bridges and finally
um number five is uh covers and makes
clear uh the cost of repairs in addition
to the cost of the ticket and clarifies
who is responsible in any event that
involves a rented
vehicle sections 2 three and four of the
bill
really just are our due diligence we
went to other sections of the statutes
that uh talk about height weight and
fines and then included the fact that
this is uh notwithstanding this bill the
other things stand so it doesn't change
any of those just reminds us that we
also have this um that's kind of similar
and that's all that's really done in
this
bill the point of the bill is not to be
punitive it's to be
preventative the best result from
passing this legislation would be to
make it more desirable for someone to go
around a covered bridge rather than
through a covered bridge when their
vehicle is too big or too heavy or will
cause damage and I hope you will help
pass this first legislation about
covered bridges since
1963 uh and uh help me by passing and
supporting this bill and I'm happy to
answer any
questions thank you um any questions
from the committee representative
Gorski thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question can you give us an idea of what
type of vehicles are causing uh the
damage on these Bridges thank you for
the question yes I can um and I think
that um uh Chief Hackett will goit more
into that but um at this point it's a
lot of it is is just plain geometry box
trucks don't fit in something that goes
like this the Box part hits the rafters
you can try to scoot your car down the
middle of a bridge but in a two-lane
Bridge that's kind of frowned upon and
uh that's one of the things people are
not aware of the heights of some things
that they rent they don't match uh
they're they just don't fit into the
covered bridge so um it is not basically
representative C I'll start at the end
of the
table thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh I was a little
curious uh do most of these Bridges have
video surveillance of any kind thank you
for bringing that up uh there is a
companion bill kind of going through um
criminal safety that would allow video
cameras on um the to be placed on them
just because a lot of these accidents
are hit and run it's hard to get um
money to fix a bill when you don't know
who did it so these they're kind of
companion bills but we were they were
developed
separately RBS and
sellers thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question is this bridge or the
bridge in general you talk about does
that go over the river to the Vermont
side and if so what happens that they're
coming from the Vermont side over to New
Hampshire and they damage the bridge on
the Vermont soil I
guess so thank you for that question
ours represent
pondon thank you some of my questions
are already answered so thank you um my
uh that leaves me with the Roman numeral
3 uh line 15 the uh towing a trailer and
where it's posted nothing in tow
I don't see any fine associated with
that specifically is there something I'm
missing on this or would it does a fine
fall under another one of the other
paragraphs that that would thank you
that would be the other dimensional
limit that's up in Roman numerals one
and two
okay any other questions from the
committee I just have one quick one line
17 Roman four um all fines under the
section shall Ure to the municipality or
agency that's responsible are there any
other examples U where the fine money
would go to anybody other than the
state because usually that's where the
fines go is to the state I just I didn't
know if there were other examples um
thank you for that question I do not
know the answer to that but I think you
should ask that of the police chief when
he comes up fair enough seeing no other
you
uh
next up chair recognizes representative
fauler in support of the bill looking
for three
minutes welcome back sir thank you think
I can be quick uh question about
surveillance kind of introduce the
subject I can attest to uh the value of
these Bridges to the tourism in the
state I see people I have four of these
bridges in my town Swansea I'm sorry I
should have introduce myself I'm Barry
fauler representing Swansea and
Richmond uh we have forign Swansea and
two in the next town over in Winchester
see people all the time coming up taking
pictures people driving up from
Connecticut New York whatever bus loads
of people come up in in leap
season and I know the bridge near me
that I drive through a couple times a
day has had uh damage from three
different vehicle impacts and was like
that through the uh Through The Fall
season uh there's a hit and run the
town's we got to budget the the funds to
fix it and it's one of those things that
they try to to do within their current
budget with u some difficulty um want to
explain the the the parallel bill has
been through criminal justice uh it
provides it it creates an exception to
allow video surveillance of bridges for
the purpose of identifying the cause of
damage to the rdge so it's I think
parallel to this bridge it doesn't
contradict anything in this bill uh I
think the two go together um and that
bill I think has got a favorable ought
to pass recommendation from from that
committee so we're looking forward to at
least that that level of U of help in
identifying and getting some some
compensation for the for the Damage Done
to to
Bridges uh that support this Bill thank
you very much thank you questions from
the committee I have one for you if
you've been involved in this sure is
there any data out there um would
indicate how many of these damages were
recommendation I it all the time it's
wasn't my fault Google I I don't know
that there's that's recorded I can tell
you that being on the street where you
know there's a bridge a quarter mile
down the street I on a daily basis see
trucks too big go down there realize
that they uh well at least a couple
times a week realize I can't make it
through and have to back up and come
back out the other way uh so I know what
happens I presume that they they got bad
information or they looked at a map and
they didn't have the information they
needed on it um if the truck is big
enough then they give up the problem I
think that we're seeing is people try to
sneak through even you
know when they think they might be able
to make it and they they realized they
didn't no I just wondering if there was
anything out there anybody else from the
committee representative foot thank you
Mr chair um I apologize for my not even
say with this but are any these Bridges
uh listed historically any these wooden
bridges and if if so I have a followup
if they
are right so um as might well speak
there is a a state Registry of historic
Bridges I think there are 50 something
58 bridges on
that um some of them have been listed in
the National register or state Register
uh most of covered bridges were built in
the 19th
century here and there I know there's
one in my town that was built in the
19th century and burned down and then
was replaced in
the I don't know the last 50
years um but an attempt to you know
replicate the original one so say most
of these are historic follow please
follow up thank you Mr chair and um so
are there any current legislation rsas
that a specific specific to
historical uh buildings or Bridges or
anything like that that would also cover
know well I mean I think we're looking
at Motor Vehicle Laws and um and
liability laws
that my experience with historic
preservation legislation hasn't
really considered that to be within the
purview of that particular so this um
you know these These are F similar to
other find for motor vehicle
violations
laws all right seeing no other questions
much I guess we'll go for information
sake looks like uh e Douglas hacket in
support of the bill looking for three
minutes
welcome there you go okay sorry about
that good afternoon um my name is uh
Chief Doug Hackett from Cornish Police
Department I'm here to speak in support
of House Bill
1457 I've been employed at Cornish PD
since 1988 or 36 years as some of you
may know Cornish is is home to four
historic covered bridges with the grand
Cornish Windsor Covered Bridge being the
most favorite the most visited and the
most traveled bridge is over 157 years
old and hundreds of vehicles pass across
it every day sadly some of those
vehicles are over height overweight and
they should not be on our
Bridge however some oversized Vehicles
arrive and realize that they're going to
have to turn around and go back 10 miles
out of their way to get to winds of
Vermont they look at that and they make
a decision to try to squeeze across the
bridge the sides of the bridge are only
have a clearance of 9' 2
in and the bridge is posted for that the
center of the
bridge has a lot more clearance and
some larger Vehicles can sneak down the
middle as long as they can stay in the
middle without any damage if the
oversized vehicle meets another vehicle
in the bridge and pulls to the right
they start snapping off
crossmembers an example of that is
attached to my hand
out an oversized truck broke off 12
crossmembers crossing the bridge we were
lucky the operator stopped on the other
side and an investigation
ensued our only option was to give him a
$62 summons for failing to obey a
traffic
sign we need this legislation to make it
a greater deterrent to crossing the
bridge than
$62 Cornish Police Department responds
to between four and eight accidents
annually involving the Cornish Windsor
Covered
Bridge I've also attached an example of
Damage Done to our Roo Hill Covered
Bridge we respond to two to three
accidents annually on that bridge the
example I'm presenting today happened in
2016 a fully loaded 72 passenger School
Bus from another state crossed that
bridge it was way over weight it was way
over height and they didn't stop an
investigation happened and again we
identified the
operator if he had stopped we could have
only find him for
$62 because he didn't we charged him
with leaving the scene of the accident
our bridges are historic and they need
to be protected please join me in
sending a message that if you ignore the
height and weight
restrictions you will have to pay and
that we won't tolerate the damage any
longer thank you thank you thank you sir
uh any questions from the committee
represent
Crawford thank you Mr chairman I'm just
curious um does your insurance company
cover the damage from the bridge when
someone does that um I I believe this my
experience from the state level being
the larger Bridge which is the
responsibility of the state there is no
insurance on it and which sell fed I
believe the town's Municipal policy I do
know they're I do know they're insured
and they're on our insurance but I don't
know the facts about the LI um the
deductibles or anything to that nature
just a follow up U so when the when
these Bridges were damaged I don't know
when they were damaged the dates on them
how did you fix them um the state fixed
the big one we closed it for a few hours
while we were trying to assess the
damage and they just came down they had
to close the bridge again for one lane
traffic and spend a day fixing the 12 or
more broken cross members the town
Bridge was done out of town funds funds
okay thank you any other questions
representative
London yes one question um you state
that the the 10 mile distance between
windmont and Cornish on that roadway is
it posted uh before any Vehicles turn on
that road that it's it's a li it's a
restricted road so what I'm trying to
get at is limiting them to turn around
10 miles prior to the bridge instead of
getting to the bridge I I don't believe
it is posted I mean again there's like
five different onlet to Route 12a um the
biggest obviously being the 103
intersection down in Claremont um but
again they all come up they all see the
sign and it's just that I think I can
squeak across and interestingly enough
the bridge on the Vermont side is
shorter than our Covered Bridge so once
they get across Frost most of the time
they have to turn around and come back
because they can't get under the Vermont
side so most of the damage that never
happens to the Windsor side because they
can't get to it they have to come from
New Hampshire thank you represent
sers thank you Mr chair uh question
about video it's do you have any video
there now and how would you ticket or
can you ticket by just getting a video
um there is no video now that's why we
introduced the legislation to allow for
the video surveillance of the bridge um
in the companion bill um I my
understanding of that bill is is it's
only to identify the damage it's not
meant to watch the video back and just
issue citations for crossing the bridge
um it's meant that video bill was
intended to identify who damaged the
bridge I would venture to say and I
don't have a hard and fast number um
probably nine out of 10 times we go for
chunks of the bridge in the middle of
the the travel Lane and there's nobody
there it's very rare that we identify
who causes the damage to
these any other questions representative
Jones Thank you Mr chairman um as I've
been investigating this um at what other
states do uh some have before you get to
the bridge they have a crossbar at the
same height or less height uh so you hit
that first instead of come but I if if
I'm correct that I cross the Cornish
Bridge there' be no room for a cross bar
there because it's it's a turn right off
the highway correct it's literally from
Route 12a onto the bridge the ramp is
maybe a two lengths of this desk before
you're into the bridge and additionally
with it I you hear everybody say it
makes them ugly because you're putting
this big monstrosity in front of our
historic covered bridges um if I could
just also add somebody had a question
earlier that wasn't answered
historically it's box truckses box
trucks
motor homes and school buses that are
causing the damage from my experience um
a significant number of motor homes as
well usually they're shearing off their
AC units that are up on top of the
camper on the cross members going in or
out I did have a uh a flatbed tow truck
with a cabota tractor on it fit going up
Bridge representative s clear
thank you Mr
chair would you in your capacity of
chief chief uh from this point forward
try to get the state to invest in more
signage like was brought up by a couple
other reps further down the roads
because I I understand you don't want it
right in front of the bridge for you
know the viewing but definitely further
back would could you would you be in
favor of doing that I I would be in
favor of putting a sign further back
down the road as well my fear sir is in
my uh
36 years I've become a little bit
pessimistic and they don't follow the 9
foot two sign they're not going to
follow the sign 10 miles down the road
just quick s my I guess uh I want to be
clearer not not a
9.2 but no trucks no school buses no box
trucks it would have to be a really big
sign that's okay because you have a big
problem I do have a big problem exactly
and and the issue is is putting it
further back like it would proba it's
really tough to if you know the
geography specifically speaking of the
Windsor Cornish Covered Bridge um
there's a sharp corner before it and
there's no real place to put it I've
thought in my head before technology has
to say you know 200 fet before you get
to the intersection with the bridge
measure what's going by and if it's over
9 feet flash a sign saying no left turn
you know I'm trying to come up with
anything to to do I'm not against Des
sign further down um but there's so many
turns and stuff off that road where
would be the correct place to put it
that would get their
attention and if they're only a mile
away and they still have to turn around
and go back nine
miles maybe 10 miles back thank thank
you any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much uh next up chair recognizes match
gra from the Hampshire Municipal
Association
Bill thank you Mr chair n g for the
municipal Association I'm glad to join
you all again today uh we are in support
of this bill uh over the last couple
years uh covered bridges have been
damaged in Campton Cornish Jackson
Lancaster and Swansea to the extent that
they've actually made the news as you've
heard from the police chief of course
many many bridges throughout the state
get damaged much more frequently that
doesn't make the news many of those are
owned by municipalities and therefore
the municipal taxpayers are the ones
footing the bill to repair those um our
hope is that by um increasing the
penalties for striking the bridge for
causing this type of damage that it will
discourage people from engaging in that
type of activity as well as uh recover
some of the costs for the damages
obviously it won't recover the full
costs um but the hope is that if we can
at least decrease some of the damage um
we can put uh a better foot uh to to
this problem I'm happy to answer any
questions the commane may have thank you
any questions from the committee seeing
none thank you again thank you and our
final speaker signed up for this bill is
Bill Caswell uh representing the
National Society for the preservation of
covered
bridges um welcome in support of the
bill yeah in full disclosure I grew up
underneath the Swiftwater covered bridge
in the big Eddie
excellent so yes I'm Bill Caswell
president of the National Society for
the preservation of cover Bridges and
I'm speaking in favor of the bill uh our
organization if you're not familiar with
it is an all volunteer nonprofit
organization founded in
1954 to advocate for um the needs of our
nation's historic cover
Bridges we receive damage reports either
through um news or from our members
sending information about incidents
throughout the country I mean this is
definitely not a New Hampshire problem
or uh anywhere that has cover Bridges
open to traffic are experiencing similar
things and to answer the uh well not so
much answer but to provide some more
information about earlier questions um
what we hear is a lot of rental trucks
the U-Haul trucks the rider trucks where
maybe the driver is inexperienced not
familiar with the height of the vehicle
so even if they saw the 9 foot2
clearance they don't necessarily realize
even though it's printed right on the
back of the truck um that their vehicle
is 12 feet high and it's going to get
stuck so um it's there's a lot to you
know yes we need to better inform people
how do you get that information out to
those people um who are not even aware
of the size of their vehicle when they
try to
cross we realize that there are many
instance that we never even hear about
um my wife and I let a tour of cover
Bridges a three-day tour in Northern
Vermont last September and nearly every
bridge we stopped to visit of the 33 on
that trip um had some kind of scarring
from vehicle damage so I mean it might
not have been recent it could have
happened over a period of time but also
one of the stops we watched a fully
loaded school bus drive over a cover
bridge with a uh three-ton weight limit
and that's and I contacted the town
selectman to inquire about that and the
bus had been running that route twice a
day for the last two years exceeding
greatly exceeding that speed that um
weight limit so of course you know we
contacted the Vermont agency of
Transportation who wanted to go out and
and do an inspection on the bridge to
see what kind of long-term damage might
have been caused by that vehicle
crossing a bridge all the time I don't
know the results of that inspection but
you know it it definitely got people
aware when when we contacted
them the
uh again most of these incidents are
fairly minor um scrapes and you know
broken boards on the portals uh the roof
braces yeah they're they get hit a lot
and that's you know then you're in a
point where you need to repair the
bridge uh there have been a couple
extreme examples which I wrote in my
written testimony so I won't bother
taking time to explain through that and
the $62 fine is certainly not much of a
deterrent really um you know there's
some areas where I've been told um like
a a company vehicle that's clearly over
the weight limit will regularly run
through a bridge because it's the
shortest route to wherever the going I
mean we've seen you know UPS trucks
FedEx trucks um go across these Bridges
and sometimes they shouldn't um but
that's their shortest route I don't know
or nor do I have any expectations that
you know increasing the fine from $62 to
$1,000 is going to alleviate the problem
but it is definitely a step in the right
direction to uh discourage people from
from doing this along with some of the
other methods that were mentioned uh
regarding the steel bars I'm totally in
favor for them although I realize that
they are an isore uh but from standpoint
of putting that on a public Highway the
Federal Highway Administration does
frown on doing introducing any
additional low clearance structures to
the roadway so that's that's something
from the federal standpoint that if your
road is receiving federal funds for
anything you'd have to consider
that um there are other methods that
have been attempted and sometimes
successful uh there have been a couple
uh cover Bridges especially and it might
even be suitable in in the Cornish
Windsor case where it is close to an
intersection where they physically
narrowed the width of the intersection
to the point where a large truck can't
make the turn so it's you know only a a
you know a truck a pickup truck or or a
car would be able to get around the
corner in the first place so that kind
of restricts the size of the vehicle
that could get onto the bridge at all so
there are some other Alternatives that
you know in addition but um we do feel
that increase in the fines is a place to
start uh you know people they'll get
people's attention when they have to
Shell out $1,000 instead of
62 so that's all I had thank you very
much question from the
committee seeing done thank you very
much thank you
okay that is the last person I have
signed up to speak on House Bill 1457 so
I'll close the public
hearing and that my friends is the last
house bill of this term
so uh I was hoping to originally exec a
few of them today but however with a
ranking member having to leave early
that's out so next week I'm going to
schedule Tuesday all of the bills that
we have left to that will be the nine
that we had today plus there are six I
believe six
outstanding so we will have a busy day
of exact session next week um there's a
couple of the bills I know that are
already uh have some amendments being in
the works so I just ask everybody to
look at the bills read through them if
you have ideas for amendments or issues
just make sure you get them here by
Tuesday we're going to bring them all up
Tuesday um obviously we reserve the
right to delay if we find something we
can hammer out that the amendments may
not have accomplished but it I really
would like to get our work done if we
don't get it done this coming Tuesday
then we'll have to come back for another
one that's
so uh I will probably start at 10: to
give us both both sides an opportunity
to clock us from 9: to 10: uh I'll
schedule them all for morning session if
we run long although we don't usually
run long in exec sessions we do have the
afternoon if we need it um so but again
I'm just trying to uh keep moving along
here uh and the more you folks help the
better it'll it'll accomplish that so
any questions from anybody on the
committee that's where we stand thanks
everybody again we'll see you next
Thursday
that